Und ich bin ein ganz großer Mensch.
Auf Fritz, drei Stunden lang bis ein Uhr. Vielleicht ganz kurz mal zur Einleitung. Ich hab auch lange Zeit gedacht, Chaos Radio, das ist so quasi 19 Zoll Radio mit lauter schwierigen Computerdingen. Das ist es nur begrenzt. Im Gegenteil. Es betrifft Dinge, die uns alle angehen. Es betrifft die Welt, in der wir leben, die Gesellschaft, in der wir leben und ganz viele Dinge, die sowohl politisch als auch mit euch ganz persönlich zu tun haben. Heute geht es um die biometrische Vollerfassung. Das ist ein sehr böses, kompliziertes und maximal undurchsichtiges Wort. Das werden wir noch klären in den nächsten Stunden hier auf Fritz. Es geht unter anderem um das Meldewesen und auch um die Frage, wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über euch wissen? Ihr seid eingeladen, mitzudiskutieren unter 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt auch zu uns ins Netz gehen unter fritz.de. Da gibt es ein Board. Ihr könnt auch auf ccc.de gehen. Da gibt es einen Link zum Chat und ihr könnt natürlich auch Mails schicken an chaosradio.ccc.de. Es werden heute so Punkte besprochen werden, wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder aber Fotofahndung oder Personenkennziffer oder aber Bundestrojaner und damit sind wir so ein bisschen bei der Nachfolge der letzten Sendung, Chaosradio 122, wo es ganz viel um den Bundestrojaner ging. Das ist jetzt fast schon eine Woche, einen Monat her. Da sollten wir jetzt mal ein Update geben, was bislang passiert ist. Bei mir sind wie gesagt Constanze, Starwag und Frank vom CCC. Wer will anfangen jetzt da die Decke von dem?
Constanze.
Ich fange mal an. Da hat sich halt einiges ergeben seit dem letzten Mal, wo wir die Sendung zum Bundestrojaner gemacht haben und zwar hat unterdessen das Bundesinnenministerium zugeben müssen, dass der Bundestrojaner schon ein Praxis ist, also dass bereits einige dieser Trojaner in der freien Wildbahn genutzt wurden.
Also wenn man bislang gedacht hat, ja das wird besprochen und das kommt mal irgendwann, die Dinger sind längst unterwegs.
Und schwierig ist daran vor allem, dass es keine gesetzliche Grundlage hat, sondern nur so ein Erlass von dem ehemaligen Bundesinnenminister Schiedi ist. Und auf diese neuen Erkenntnisse hin hat Herr Schäuble sich dann entschieden, jetzt erstmal ein Moratorium zu erlassen, sodass aktuell der Bundesdrojaner quasi suspended ist. Also wird erstmal für eine noch ungewisse Zeit nicht zum Einsatz kommen. So lange, bis eben die Gesetze dafür in die Wege gelettet werden.
Ein paar Fragen tauchen dabei natürlich auf. Zum einen, würde ich erkennen, wenn so ein Ding da ist?
Na ja, man hat jetzt einige Spekulationen gesehen. Also ich hab bedüngst in einem Blog gesehen und auch in einer Zeitung, dass es tatsächlich Leute gibt, die behaupten, sie hätten einen Bundestrojaner auf ihrem Rechner gefunden. Aber für mich ist relativ zweifelhaft, ob das wirklich so stimmt.
Frank, du sagst, na ja, warum?
Na ja, es gibt Leute, die machen sich natürlich schon ihre Gedanken. Wenn der Rechner jetzt plötzlich anfängt, wenn die Festplatte rattert und der Rechner irgendwas tut oder irgendwie langsam wird, dann kann es natürlich auch irgendwie ein anderes Schadprogramm sein. Es kann natürlich auch ganz was Harmloses sein, dass das Betriebssystem mal ein paar Daten umsortiert. Das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt sofort ein Grund zur Beunruhigung. Grundsätzlich besteht die Gefahr natürlich schon, dass da irgendwie so komisches Software im Umlauf ist. Die muss natürlich nicht von den Behörden sein, sondern kann auch von irgendwelchen anderen Leuten kommen. Jetzt konkret den Nachweis zu führen, dass da tatsächlich irgendwelche Behörden auf dem Rechner rumschnüffeln, den hat bisher noch keiner erbracht.
Kann ich mit den handelsüblichen Mitteln, die mir als Autonomalverbraucher gegeben sind, versuchen so ein Ding fernzuhalten, also mit einer klassischen Firewall und irgendwie einem McAfee oder Anti-Viren-Scanner oder so und denken, da ist mein Haus zu.
Da ist man als normaler Computer-Benutzer ziemlich hilflos. So eine Anti-Viren-Software und eine Firewall hilft schlicht gar nicht, weil der Bundestro ja nur so geplant ist, dass es schon eine sehr spezielle Software ist, die für denjenigen, der eben ausgespäht werden soll, geschrieben ist und eben genau diesen ausschnüffelt und nicht so eine breite Schad- oder Spionagesoftware.
Gibt es da wieder eine Menge Leute, ich zähl mich da auch dazu, die sagen, naja, ich hab jetzt irgendwie nicht wirklich irgendwas angestellt in meinem Leben und müsste mich jetzt auch nicht als Problemfall betrachten. Warum sollte Vater Staat auf meiner Festplatte rumschnüffeln oder aber mich irgendwie am Hauptbahnhof fotografieren und irgendwo abspeichern? Ich hab doch nichts getan, ich hab doch also auch nichts zu befürchten.
Ja, natürlich, man hat nichts zu verbergen. Die Debatte kann man in diesem Zusammenhang immer führen. Werden wir bestimmt auch heute noch mit den Hörern ein bisschen darüber reden, aber ich hab da mittlerweile auch eine relativ kurze Antwort, nämlich wenn jemand zu mir sagt, dass er nichts zu verbergen hat, dann denk ich immer, oh man, der hat aber echt ein armer Leben.
Außerdem besteht halt immer die Gefahr, dass man halt durch Zufall trotzdem irgendwie ausgespielt wird. Also wenn man zum Beispiel in einer WG wohnt und da der Bundestrojaner auf einen Rechner von einem Mitbewohner installiert werden soll und irgendwie dann erwischt sein Rechner, das heißt irgendwie, man kann halt immer betroffen sein, obwohl man es halt irgendwie eigentlich nichts zu verbergen hat.
Na, die Konsequenz dessen wäre jetzt, paranoid zu werden und zu sagen, ich schaffe alle Computer ab und mache jegliche Kommunikation, die ich habe, mit einem Bleistift und einem Zettel. Oder mit dem Handy.
Also man kann natürlich schon ein paar Vorsichtsmaßnahmen treffen, aber eine absolut hundertprozentige Sicherheit gegen so einen Eingriff des Staates gibt es nicht, weil einfach die Möglichkeiten zu vielfältig sind, auf so einen Rechner zu kommen. Und letztendlich kann ich auch niemand mehr trauen. Ich kann meinem Internetprovider nicht mehr trauen. Ich kann dem Hersteller von der Software, von meinem Betriebssystem nicht mehr trauen. Ich kann möglicherweise nicht mal dem Computerhersteller mehr trauen. Und dann habe ich als Computerbenutzer, als unbedarfter Computerbenutzer, wirklich verloren.
Computerbenutzer ist das eine. Wir haben vorhin schon mal kurz gesprochen, auch in der Geschichte vom Chaosradio. Gab es vor fast zehn Jahren die erste Sendung zum Thema der Staat spät die Bürger aus und gläserner Bürger. Und wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über mich wissen, darüber werden wir heute auch noch reden. Auch wenn in der letzten Zeit die Diskussion darüber etwas offener geführt wird, weil solche Geschichten wie zum Beispiel die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die ja jetzt durch ist, viele Leute schon wach werden lässt. Ist ja sowas keine Sache, die erst seit zwei Jahren irgendwie im Raum steht. Sowas gibt es ja schon länger und deswegen gibt es auch Instanzen wie den Chaos Computer Club und auch das Chaos Radio, wo sowas immer wieder besprochen wird. Darüber können wir heute auch noch eine Weile reden. Aber selbst wenn ich jetzt kein Computer benutze, sondern per Internet oder per E-Mail kommuniziere, das ist ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr so einfach zu haben. Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist das Stichwort, was schon ein paar Mal gefallen ist. Vielleicht kann einer von euch noch mal zwei Sätze dazu verlieren, was das für jeden von uns einzelnen bedeutet.
Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ein Projekt, das wieder mal auf eine Initiative der EU zurückgeht. Und zwar ist da vor kurzem beschlossen worden, dass alle Handy, Festnetz und Internetdaten, also die Kommunikationsdaten, wer mit wem, jetzt verdachtsunabhängig in einem Zeitraum von sechs Monaten gespeichert werden. Also quasi von allen Bürgern, weil ja heute jeder eine von diesen drei Arten kommuniziert.
Aber habt ich doch nicht so, es werden ja nicht die Inhalte gespeichert, es werden ja nur die Informationen drüber gespeichert.
Also irgendjemand weiß, dass wir heute miteinander telefoniert haben?
Also wer halt irgendwie bei Chaosradio anruft, das wissen halt der Staaten. Aber in Deutschland ist es ja noch nicht ganz so schlimm, irgendwie in Frankreich gab es irgendwie genau heute die Aussage, dass sie irgendwie auch sämtliche Passworte von Mailclients und so weiter irgendwie auch mit speichern wollen. Das heißt irgendwie, da sind dem Staate keine wirklich großen Grenzen gesetzt. Also auch was die Zeit uns so betrifft. Also die EU-Rechtlinie sagt halt irgendwie sechs Monate bis zwei Jahre und irgendwie die Nationalstaaten können es dann umsetzen, wie sie das gerne wollen.
Wir kommen heute eigentlich zur biometrischen Vollerfassung. Da werden wir noch genauer darauf eingehen. Es geht ums Meldewesen, um Ausweise, die ihr habt, um den Pass, den ihr habt. Was steht da eigentlich alles drauf? Es gab vor längerer Zeit schon die Diskussion um den elektronischen Pass, der ja auch schon beschlossen ist und nach und nach eingeführt wird, wo nicht nur mehr drin steht, wer ich bin und wo ich wohne und wie ich heiße und wie groß ich bin und welche Augenfarbe ich habe, sondern da stehen auch ganz andere Sachen drin.
Also der biometrische Reisepass, der jetzt von der Weide eingeführt wird, hat anfangs nur ein digitales Gesichtsbild gehabt. Also im Prinzip ein Passbild wie früher, nur eben in digitaler Form. Und jetzt werden momentan schon in Deutschland Pässe so testweise ausgegeben, die eben die Fingerabdrücke enthalten. Und zwar von zwei Fingern und wenn es geht, von den beiden Zeigefingern.
Also in digitaler Form heißt es in dem Fall, dass sie einen RFID, also einen Funkchip, eingebaut haben, wo halt genau diese Daten gespeichert sind und dann halt auch über die Luftschutzstelle ausgelesen werden können.
Moment, Luftschutzstelle ist mir zu technisch. Das bedeutet, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo mich zwischen Potsdam und Belitz befinde, kann irgendjemand irgendeinen Satelliten anwerfen und weiß, wo ich bin, obwohl ich mein Handy ausarbe oder was?
Also Luftschutzstelle heißt in dem Fall, also laut Standard redet man da so von 10 bis 30 Zentimeter. Kann halt irgendwie, wenn man ein bisschen die Leistung hochdreht, irgendwie sicherlich auf irgendwie ein, zwei Meter hochgedreht werden, aber halt irgendwie nicht mit Satellitenordnung. Also da sind wir noch ein bisschen entfernt.
Also kurz die Idee bei diesen Reisepässen ist, dass da einfach ein Chip drin ist. Und das ist ein ähnlicher Chip wie bei einer Telefonkarte auch. Bei meiner Telefonkarte habe ich diese Gold-Kontaktflächen oben, die stecke ich in die Telefonzelle rein. Und dann werden die Daten damit übertragen. Und bei diesem Funk-Chip ist es so, dass die Daten eben nicht über diese Kontakte übertragen werden, sondern tatsächlich wie im Prinzip einen Funksender, wie ein WLAN oder sowas. Nur, dass es alles auf eine kürzere Reichweite angelegt ist. Das heißt, der Grenzbeamte nimmt diesen Passlegenden auf ein Lesegerät und dann werden die Daten erdrahtlos übertragen. Wobei natürlich...
Wohin werden die übertragen?
In ein Lesegerät. Das heißt, da wird also von einer Grenzkontrolle dieses digitale Gesichtsbild ausgelesen. Dieses digitale Gesichtsbild, das ist wichtig, damit ich dann auch eine biometrische Vermessung machen kann von meinem Gesicht automatisch. Und später auch dann die Fingerabdrücke. Das heißt also, das ist ein Fingerabdruckscanner, da leg ich meinen Finger drauf und die werden dann verglichen mit den gespeicherten aus dem Ausweis.
Damit sind wir auch beim Thema dieser Sendung. Damit kann man ein schönes Bild, ich reise irgendwo ein, mein Passwort da eingelesen und dann kann, wenn irgendein Computer mein Gesichtsbild gescannt hat, irgendeine Mautbrücke, ein Foto machen und man weiß, an welcher Raststätte ich mir einen Kaffee gekauft habe, weil den habe ich wiederum mit einer EC-Karte bezahlt.
Das Schöne dabei ist, dass du das Gesichtsbild ja schon abgibst, wenn du den ausweist und beantragst. Das heißt also, in dem Moment, wo du den holst, wo du den beantragst, musst du ja schon ein Foto hinterlegen und später dann noch deine Fingerabdrücke und in dem Moment sind die gespeichert. Dann sind wir aber eigentlich auch schon mitten im Thema. Nämlich die Frage ist, was passiert mit diesen Daten, wo werden die gespeichert, wie werden sie aufbewahrt und wer darf darauf zugreifen?
Und bei der Frage, wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über euch wissen, darüber könnt ihr mal nachdenken. Und uns dann auch anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. Ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, dazu mitzudiskutieren. Wir werden jetzt ein bisschen ins Thema einführen. Frank hat da eine ganz kurze Einleitung vorbereitet. Und dann denke ich mal, nach den Nachrichten wird die Diskussion losgehen. Und wir haben auch noch ein kleines Rätsel. Aber das gibt's dann in 10 Minuten etwa, oder? Okay, ihr müsst noch hier an den Rechner strecken. Ich hab eine hervorragende Musik ausgesucht. Die ist schon rattenalt. Warte mal, 2007. Die ist jetzt fast 23 Jahre alt. Hey, herzlichen Glückwunsch, aktuelles Thema. Wir leben im Computerstaat abwärts, waren das im Chaos Radio Teil 123 auf Fritz. Im Studio sind Starbark, Frank und Constanze vom CCC. Es geht heute um die biometrische Vollerfassung Schrägstrich, Meldewesen in Deutschland. Frank, das ist dein Auftritt, du musst erklären, was das ist.
Genau, also eigentlich dieses Meldewesen ist erst mal eine ganz, ganz analoge Sache gewesen. Es hat erst mal überhaupt nichts mit Computern zu tun, weil das Meldewesen in dem Sinne gibt es schon ziemlich lange. Und so in unseren Breitengraden kann man sagen, dass der Anfang davon genommen wurde im guten alten Preußen. Da ging es nämlich darum, festzustellen, wen haben wir jetzt beim Militär, bzw. wen wollen wir zum Militär haben, also vor allem die Männer. Und da ist eigentlich so das erste Mal diese Erfassung der Bürger aufgetaucht. Das war natürlich dann auch interessant, die Hochzeiten zu registrieren und Geburten, dass man da also mal sehen konnte, irgendwie ist möglicherweise jemand schon mal verheiratet. Irgendwie noch so, denn geht es halt darum, wer ist jetzt sozusagen heiratsfähig, im Sinne von ist nicht schon verheiratet. Das ist natürlich auch ganz interessant zu wissen, in so einem Register zu haben. Das dümpelt dann bis zum Anfang des 20.
Weißt du, wie es gemacht wurde irgendwie? Also da gab es ja noch keine schnellen Online-Tagmark.
Es gibt wirklich klassische Bücher und es gibt auch viele Institutionen, die diese ganzen Bücher von damals jetzt im Prinzip auf Mikrofilmen verarbeitet haben. Teilweise sind die schon über das Internet zugänglich. Das geht auch, wenn man mal angefangen hat, ein bisschen Familienforschung an. Forschung zu machen, dann wird man damit viel, ganz viel zu tun haben. Die Mormonen sind da sehr aktiv. Die haben halt das größte Archiv da.
familysearch.org.
Genau. Und ja, richtig fies wurde es dann eigentlich im Dritten Reich, als im Prinzip die, sag ich mal, die ersten aufkommenden technischen Errungenschaften der elektronischen Datenverarbeitung genutzt wurden. Das sind die sogenannten Hollerith-Maschinen gewesen, die damals von IBM dann quasi groß gemacht worden sind und im Dritten Reich da zum Einsatz kamen, um im Prinzip die Juden in Deutschland weit zentral zu erfassen, auszusortieren, um dann, sag ich mal, böse wie es ist, zum Abtransport vorzubereiten. Und das war sozusagen der erste Tiefschlag oder das erste wirklich Negativerlebnis, oder was einfach dieses Melderegister geprägt hat. Und das war eigentlich auch der ausschlaggebende Punkt für die Bundesrepublik, dass man sagte, okay, wir wollen eigentlich nie wieder so ein zentrales Melderegister haben. Wir wollen, dass die Leute zwar schon an ihren Wohnorten registriert sind, aber wir wollen möglichst datensparsam sein, wir wollen möglichst wenig Daten erheben und wir wollen, dass praktisch keiner auf diese Daten automatisiert zugreifen kann. Also sie sollen zwar immer wieder auffindbar sein, wenn man sich ummeldet, dann muss man auch was mal registrieren oder wenn man jetzt noch ein Auto zu lassen will, das sind alles so Sachen, das ist okay, da sollen die gespeichert sein oder wenn man jetzt mal wirklich jemand finden will, es müssen Personalausweise ausgestellt werden, da ist es okay, aber die Daten sollen möglichst dezentral sein, weit weg und auf keinen Fall irgendwie automatisiert durchsuchbar zugreifbar sein.
Das heißt, dass die Zulassungsstelle zwar weiß, welches Auto ich habe, sie wissen aber jetzt noch lange nicht, bei welchem Telefonanbieter ich mein Telefon angemeldet habe.
Ja, es ist gerade, wenn die Behörden untereinander Daten austauschen wollen, dann ist es zumal auch ein Problem, weil es einfach keine konsistenten, also keine gleichbleibenden Merkmale gibt. Das heißt, man muss sich wirklich bei jeder Behörde neu identifizieren und die Behörden hatten bisher keine Möglichkeit, Daten miteinander abzugleichen. Also es durfte auch keinen Datenaustausch geben, keinen automatischen. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel mal das Erlebnis, dass ich in Griechenland, das war also vor den EU-Zeiten, in Griechenland mein Personalausweis verloren hatte und dazu Botschaften mir dann so einen Behelfsausweis holen musste. Und für die war das tatsächlich richtig ein Problem, eben aus Datenschutzgründen einfach von der Meldestelle quasi meine Daten zu bekommen. Das war halt wirklich ein Act. Bei der Bundeswehr war es zum Beispiel bisher so, dass sie auch den Zweitwohnsitz nicht bekamen. Wenn es jetzt darum ging, jemanden zur Musterung ranzuziehen, da jemanden zu erfassen, dann konnten die immer nur zum Erstwohnsitz gehen, weil sie einfach aus Datenschutzgründen andere Daten nicht bekommen haben außer diesem Wohnsitz. Und das sind so Beispiele, wie das wirklich bisher ziemlich gut funktioniert hat. Diese Trennung der Behörden, die Trennung der Daten. Und das ist jetzt so gerade nach und nach dabei aufzuweichen. Darum geht es heute.
Biometrische Vollerfassung, ein kleiner Teil davon ist sozusagen das Meldewesen, das Frank vom CCC gerade eingeführt hat. Wir werden sicherlich auch noch über so Sachen reden wie die Personenkennziffer, die ja immer mal wieder im Gespräch ist, dass also jeder von uns eine von der Geburt bis zum Tod immer gleichbleibende Nummer bekommt, die man in irgendeinen Rechner reinhacken kann und dann weiß man sofort wer du bist, wo du bist und warum du bist. Wir können da sicherlich auch noch über Sachen reden wie Gesundheitskarte. Das ist auch ein ganz beliebtes Thema. Zentralregister ist auch immer schön. Und natürlich an euch die Frage, wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über euch wissen und wie viel weiß er schon? Wisst ihr das überhaupt, wie viel der Staat über euch weiß? Ruft mal an 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz.
So und wir haben noch eine ganz ganz wichtige Frage an euch, Hörer. Wir haben nämlich in den letzten Tagen, vor allem heute so ein paar Mails bekommen mit so einer komischen Zahlencode drin, mit der wir nicht so richtig was anfangen können.
Hier könnt mit einem Zahlencode nichts anfangen?
Ja, das ist ganz fürchterlich. Das ist ein rätselhafter Zahlencode und wir sind auf eure Hilfe angewiesen und möchten gerne wissen, was das ist. Ich lese dir mal vor, das sind ein paar Zahlenkolonne, das geht recht schnell, aber es ist 09F911029D74E35BD84156C5635688C0. Ich bin F911 02 9D 74 E3 5B D8 41 56 C5 63 56 88 C0. Das hat bestimmt irgendeine Bedeutung, wir können uns das aber nicht so richtig erklären. Vielleicht kann jemand von euch da draußen uns helfen, uns kurz anrufen und uns aufklären, was es damit auf sich hat. Genau.
0317797170, magst du diese Zahlenkolonne noch mal wiederholen bitte? Also die kamen in einem Mail, die ihr bekommen habt.
Ja, die kamen in einem Mail, in mehreren Mails, sind uns geschickt worden. Das ist die 09F911029D74E35BD84156C5635688C0.
Kann da jemand was mit anfangen? 0331 7097 110. Chaosradio 123 auf Fritz. Wir hatten gerade ein kleines Problem vom CCC. Die haben per Mail einen Zahlencode bekommen und können nichts damit anfangen. Am Telefon ist Harald aus Berlin. Hallo Harald, grüß dich. Was würdest du sagen, was ist das?
Von welchem?
Vom deutschen Reisepass.
Von deinem?
Ich fürchte, dass es... also ich meine Reisepassnummer sind normalerweise nicht hexadezimal. Also da hast du halt nur Zahlen drin.
Aber danke für den Tipp, Harald. Schönen Abend, tschüss. Am Telefon ist Wolfgang aus Rudow. Hallo Wolfgang, grüß dich.
Hallo. Ja, hallo, grüß dich.
Was sagst du?
Ich hab jetzt gerade nicht zuhören können, was die Leute gesagt hatten, das ist hexadezimal. Es klingt hexadezimal.
Genau.
Es ist auch hexadezimal. Es ist nur die Frage, ist es ein Mehrere, ein Mädchen, ein Vogel, kommt man nur in diese Heim? Das kann natürlich sein, dass der Mail kleint oder...
Moment, langsam, was ist das?
Der Mail kleint, also das Programm, das euch die E-Mail anzeigt, dass da vielleicht ein kleines Bildchen drin ist oder sonst...
Der Bundes-Trojaner?
Oder eine kleine Signatur, was halt der Kleid nicht richtig interpretieren kann. Und deswegen wird es halt als ASCII ausgegeben und wird dann hexadezimal anzeigt.
Nee, dafür ist doch viel zu kurz. Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Okay, Wolfgang, auf jeden Fall danke für den Tipp. Hexadezimal ist es in jedem Fall. Und wir können noch ein bisschen weiterreseln, was dieser merkwürdige Code ist. Ansonsten geht es dann nach den Nachrichten weiter im Chaosradio 123 zum Thema biometrische Vollerfassung. Wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über euch wissen? Und was weiß der Staat schon alles? Ja Übrigens, für alle, die es interessiert, was hier im Hintergrund läuft, ist Steve Buck und jetzt ist es halb elf.
Neokritzistik?
Gützantinistik?
Vor der asiatischen Archäologie?
Nach dem Abi? Vor dem Studium? Universitätigkeiten?
Nächste Woche im Überblick.
Uni im Radio? Fritz.
Und das hört. Der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert gerät wegen des Libanon-Krieges vor einem Jahr auch in den eigenen Reihen unter Druck. Außenminister Livni legte ihm den Rücktritt nahe. Ähnlich äußerte sich auch der Fraktionsvorsitzende von Olmerts Regierender Kadima Partei. Eine Untersuchungskommission hatte die Ministerpräsidenten vorgeworfen, den Krieg im Libanon voreilig begonnen zu haben, ohne andere Möglichkeiten zu prüfen. Olmert selbst lehnte einen Rücktritt bislang ab. In der Türkei hat die Partei von Regierungschef Erdogan vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen beantragt. Hintergrund ist die gescheiterte Wahl des neuen Staatspräsidenten. Weil die Opposition die Wahl boykottierte, wurde sie vom Verfassungsgericht für ungültig erklärt. Außenminister Güll will am nächsten Sonntag aber erneut für das Präsidentenamt kandidieren. Er gehört der gleichen Partei an wie Regierungschef Erdogan. Beiden wird vorgeworfen, sie wollen die Bildung eines islamischen Staates vorantreiben. Die beiden Kandidaten für das Präsidentenamt in Frankreich, Royale und Sarkozy, liefern sich in diesen Minuten ein mit Spannung erwartetes Fernsehduell. Es wird damit gerechnet, dass rund 20 Millionen Franzosen das Streitgespräch verfolgen werden. Im Rennen die Nachfolge von Präsident Chirac, kann Sarkozy jüngsten Umfang zufolge mit 52 Prozent der Stimmen rechnen. Royale käme auf 48 Prozent. Zum Sport, die deutsche Eishockey-Nationalmannschaft hat bei der WM in Russland ihren ersten Sieg gefeiert. Im dritten Spiel gewann das Team gegen Norwegen mit 5 zu 3 und sichert sich damit den Klassenerhalt. Und zum Fußball, im Halbfinale Champions League Rückspiel zwischen dem AC Mailand und Manchester United, steht es kurz vor Schluss, sprich nach 90 Minuten 3 zu 0 für Mailand. Wetter Abends und nachts ist es nur leicht bewölkt und trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 2 Grad. Am Tag dann wieder den ganzen Tag über Sonne. Die Temperaturen klettern auf bis zu 22 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Fritz A24-Schwerin in Richtung mit dem Berliner Ring zwischen Pritzweig und dem Dreig Witschok-Dosse. Besteht Gefahr durch Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Genauer gesagt, dort liegt eine Rehkadaver auf der mittleren Fahrspur. Fahren also da besonders vorsichtig. Ansonsten sind die Straßen freien. Wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Chaosradio 123 auf Fritz, heute mit Frank, Constanze und Starbark vom CCC. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über biometrische Vollerfassung, was das Meldewesen und die Erfassung der Bürger bedeutet. Das hat Frank eben ganz kurz eingeführt. Wir werden gleich noch mehr zum Thema Biometrie hören. Was ist das eigentlich und was soll das alles? Aber vorher müssen wir noch ganz kurz eine Geschichte klären. Ihr habt erzählt, ihr habt gerade eine Mail bekommen mit einem merkwürdigen Zahlencode. Ihr wisst nicht genau, was es ist. Wir hatten eben schon gerade jemand am Telefon, der gesagt hat, es ist auf jeden Fall ein Hexadezimalcode. Da wird meine Mathematik schon ganz dünn. Und am Telefon ist Jan, der kann vielleicht noch mehr sagen.
Da ist der geschnackte HD-DVD-Code.
Der was?
Und zwar gibt es jetzt zwei neue Videoformate für Datenträger. Einmal Blu-ray und einmal HD-DVD.
Das ist das, wo sie sich nicht entscheiden können, was jetzt richtig ist.
Genau. Die können sich nicht entscheiden, überhaupt nicht. Allerdings können sich die Hacker ganz gut entscheiden, was sie gesagt haben. Egal welches, von beiden Gebäuden ist nicht verschlüsselt. Und der wurde vor einiger Zeit schon geknackt und heute hat den irgendjemand bei wie heißt das?
digg.com reingestellt.
Ist nicht das erste Mal, Google hat den auch schon drin gehabt, musste den rauslöschen. Und heute hat Digg den drin gehabt, hat den gelöscht und die Community hat allerdings gesagt, sie möchten den gerne drin haben. Und Digg hat sich demnach irgendwie einem enormen Ansturm gebeugt und hat den jetzt reingestellt wieder.
Dann müssen wir ihn jetzt natürlich auch aus den ganzen Streams und aus der Vergangenheit rausschneiden.
Genau, die müssen jetzt aus eurem Begegnungshaus raus. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt diesen Key hat, dann kann man quasi auch diese DVDs kopieren oder ungeschützt angucken?
Doch nicht kopieren, wir sind ja noch keine Robkopierer.
Das war mir wichtig, dass du das jetzt nochmal sagst, Jan.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Es geht einfach nur darum, dass man den auch mit Systemen gucken kann, für die es keine Software gibt, die nicht unterstützt werden von unserer großen, großen, tollen Musikindustrie und mehr geht es da ja gar nicht.
Im Endeffekt war das jetzt sowas wie so Doku für Große. Danke Jan für den Anruf.
Danke für die Aufklärung.
So, dann hätten wir das auch geklärt, was ihr für komische Mails bekommt. Dann können wir uns jetzt endlich wieder dem Thema widmen.
Genau, es geht uns Melderegister und das ist ein Begriff, der ist schon gefallen, die sogenannte Personenkennziffer. Und da müssen wir auch ein bisschen zurück in die Geschichte gehen, nämlich ungefähr so in die 70er Jahre, in den 60er Jahre.
Hab ich so ein Ding eigentlich, eine Personenkennziffer?
Nee, du hast sowas noch nicht. Und wir sind auch alle ganz glücklich darüber, dass wir das nicht haben. Es gibt in Amerika ist sowas abgewandelt in der sogenannten Social Security Number, also in der Sozialversicherungsnummer versteckt oder enthalten. Das kennt ihr vielleicht aus dem Fernsehen, aus Filmen. Das ist eine ganz, ganz wichtige Identifikationsnummer. Und wenn die wegkommt, im Sinne von, dass sie irgendjemand bekannt wird, dann hat man ganz, ganz großes Problem, weil man muss diese Nummer angeben, wenn man ein Konto eröffnet, wenn man ein Auto mieten möchte.
Also wenn ich deine Nummer hab, bin ich du quasi?
Schon fast, ja, genau. Da ist es besonders verschärft, weil nicht mehr viel zusätzliche Identifikationsmöglichkeiten vorgesehen sind, sondern diese Nummer ist quasi wie deine Personenkennziffer, wie der Name schon sagt. Es gibt in der Schweiz und Österreich im Prinzip auch. In Deutschland hat man sich aber eben gerade darum, man wollte es nicht haben, man hat es wirklich abgelehnt, weil man einfach diese zentralen Datenzusammenführungen nicht haben wollte. Man wollte wirklich alles sozusagen dezentral haben, verteilt haben, überall ausgelegt. Und es sollte keine Zentralfassung dieser Personen geben. Unsere Personenkennziffer, seine Zahl, die bekommt man von Geburt an und behält man bis zum Tod oder auch 20 Jahre darüber hinaus. Und es ist eben eine Sache, die wirklich so in unseren Gesetzen zwar nicht ganz wörtlich festgeschrieben ist, die aber immer wieder von Entscheidungen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht immer wiederholt wird. Nein, sowas wollen wir nicht, sowas ist nicht im Sinne der Bundesrepublik. Das ging also als erstes los als 1967, es die ersten Gesetzentwürfe dafür gab. Damals hat aber schon der Rechtsausschuss des Bundestages und später auch das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt, nein, es darf so eine Personenkennziffer nicht geben. Das ist also gegen die Ideen von diesem verzeiheten, von diesem dezentralen Melderegister. Da ging es also um so eine quasi Minivolkszählung, die damals gemacht wurde, sogenannte Mikrozensus. Später ist das Ganze dann nochmal aufgekommen, die Diskussion, und ist dann auch wieder vom Bundesverfassungsgericht landet. Da ging es dann um die Volkszählung. Da war also wieder die Frage, dürfen die Menschen in Deutschland so erfasst werden, zentral erfasst werden, mit einer Nummer versehen werden. Da ging es also um die Kennnummer, die auf diesen Fragebögen, die da drauf war. Da haben sie gesagt, nein, es muss deutlich getrennt sein. Deutsche Bürger sind keine Nummern, sondern werden über Namen und Geburtsdatum kann man sich identifizieren. Außerdem gibt es ja für Personalausweise oder Reisepässe. Damit kann man sich als der ausgeben und sicher identifizieren. Wir brauchen diese Nummer nicht und wir wollen sie nicht. Und das ist eigentlich bis heute, hat diese Rechtsprechung noch Bestand. Und jetzt gibt es aber verschiedene Ansätze, das wieder aufzuweichen. Eine ist die sogenannte Wirtschaftsidentifikationsnummer. Das ist quasi so eine neuartige Steuernummer. Nur, dass sie von Geburt an an jeden vergeben werden sollen.
Obwohl ich als bis 18-Jähriger noch keine Steuern zahle, wenn ich dann nicht einer steuerpflichtigen Arbeit nachgehe.
Ja, genau. Das kann aber trotzdem sein, weil irgendwann wirst du halt Steuern zahlen und dann hast du dir die Nummer schon mal vorsorgt. Wie praktisch. Genau.
Dann muss man die nicht mehr beantragen.
Genau. Und die andere versteckte Einführung von so einer Personenkennziffer ist über die biometrischen Merkmale. Wenn nämlich spätestens dann, wenn die Fingerabdrücke bei uns in den Pässen gespeichert sind, dann haben wir ein unveränderliches Merkmal, was quasi eine Zahlenfolge ist. So ähnlich, wie wir sie gerade vorgelesen haben. Von der Länge her vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger, ein bisschen umfangreicher. Aber es ist einfach eine Kennziffer, eine mathematische oder eine numerische Kennung, die aus den Fingerabdrücken von meinen Fingern, die sich auch über mein Leben nicht verändern, festgelegt sind.
Die dich halt eindeutig identifiziert.
Und das ist auch der Grund, warum wir eigentlich heute auch über Meldewesen und Personenkennziffer reden, weil nämlich de facto diese Einführung der biometrischen Merkmale und die Diskussion darum, wie die gespeichert werden, eigentlich ein Thema sind. Also Biometrie und PKZ, also Personenkennziffer gehören halt zusammen.
Da gibt es gleich noch einen interessanten Anruf von Stefan aus Lichtenberg. In der DDR gab es ja auch eine Personenkennzahl. In der DDR gab es, bist du DDR-Ossi?
Ich bin etwas älterer Jahrgang und deswegen kenne ich das aus der DDR. Und da gab es eine Personenkennzahl.
Hast du damit direkt Kontakt gehabt oder?
Na sicher doch. Jeder, der einen Personenausweis gekriegt hat, hat seine Personenkennzahl gekriegt.
Was stand da drin?
Das war eine lange Nummer halt.
Genau.
Und die war eben eindeutig, die musste man überall angeben. Und die hat man überall angegeben.
Dann kannst du mal ein paar Beispiele nennen. Also wo hast du die angegeben, also wo hast du nicht deinen Ausweis gezeigt, sondern irgendwie die Personenkennziffer angegeben?
Das sind doch schon ein paar Jahre hier.
Viel interessanter ist vor allen Dingen die Frage, diese Daten gibt es ja irgendwo noch. Gibt es diese DDR-PKZs irgendwo noch?
Na ja, klar ist auf jeden Fall, dass interessanterweise diese sogenannte zentrale Personendatenbank ab genau 1984 funktionsfähig war. Also schon 1970 wurde die geplant. Und dann hat umgesetzt über mehrere Jahre. Ich denke schon, dass die Daten natürlich noch bestehen, aber so aktuell werden da die heutigen Ermittlungsbehörden keinen Zugriff mehr haben.
Bei der Stasi-Unterlagenbehörde? Also ich mein, wonach hat denn die Stasi irgendwie ihre Daten klassifiziert? Doch wahrscheinlich, also ich meine, es naheliegt, dass sie dann auch die PKZ genommen haben.
Also vermutlich hat sicherlich die Stasi auf diese Daten zurückgegriffen, aber die ist ja nun heute auch nicht mehr existent.
Also wenn das vielleicht jemand, weiß ja aber die Börtler Behörde zum Beispiel, also wenn das jemand weiß irgendwie, ob die Stasi die zum Beispiel benutzt hat, die PKZ, dann könnt ihr ja mal Bescheid sagen, das wäre interessant zu wissen.
Okay Stefan, wir sind also erstmal soweit, du hattest eine Personenkennzahl und wir sind jetzt in der Diskussion, dass man möglicherweise wieder eine kriegen wird und warum man ihn nicht haben möchte. Ja, damit wünsch ich dir einen wunderbaren Abend.
Stasi 2.0. Punkt.
So, Personenkennzahl hatten wir gerade abgehandelt. Das Wort biometrisch fiel schon ein paar Mal. Was bedeutet das im Detail?
Biometrisch, also Biometrie ist die Vermessung von Körpermerkmalen. Dazu zählen halt so Sachen wie die Finger, Gesichtsbilder oder halt auch so dynamische Sachen wie die Stimme oder zum Beispiel auch das Tippverhalten.
Wie Tippverhalten?
Also das ist eine Idee, die noch nicht so wirklich ausgereift ist. Also es gibt schon eine Anwendungssoftware dafür, die halt Benutzer anhand ihres Tippverhaltens klassifiziert.
Also wie ich quasi um eine Tastatur Texte eingebe.
Soll ich mal kurz vormachen?
Das ist eindeutig konstant so, also man hat man deutlich gehört. Das wär ich. Nee, also es gibt halt tatsächlich eine Software, die das tut, die halt so anhand von irgendwie Geschwindigkeit oder irgendwie Tastendynamik, also wie doll man anschlägt, versucht herauszufinden, wer da gerade in Benutzung ist. Das ist halt jetzt nicht so eine direkte als Login Ersatz, sondern halt irgendwie als Hintergrund laufen lassen. Das heißt, wenn man mal schnell aufs Klo geht und irgendwie der Arbeitskollege an deinen Rechner rangeht, dann soll halt die Software irgendwie merken, nach irgendwie 20 Sekunden oder so, dass da jetzt jemand anders tippt und dann halt den Rechner sperren. Also prinzipiell eine relativ gute Idee, aber ob das halt so funktioniert, ist halt die andere Frage.
Ich gab da zwei interessante Worte in deinem Satz, prinzipiell und relativ.
Also es ist natürlich so, dass man alle Merkmale, die man sich so vorstellen kann, als biometrische Merkmale ansehen kann. Ich kenne zum Beispiel so Tests mit Ohrvolumen. Also wo man zum Beispiel sich ein Handy ans Ohr hält und dieses Handy eben auch einen Sensor enthält und damit das Ohrvolumen messen kann und das eben auch sehr individuell für Menschen.
Also die gießen da kein Wasser rein oder sowas, sondern was sie halt tun, ist das Echo. Sie schicken halt weißes Rauschen rein und gucken halt, wie das weiße Rauschen reflektiert wird.
Also bevor ich jetzt durchdrehe oder denke, ich hab zu viele James Bond Filme geguckt, das gibt's wirklich. Also ich hab mein Telefon an der Hand oder irgendjemand guckt, wie voluminös mein Ohr ist.
Also indem er einfach Schallwellen, in diesem Fall war es Musik, in dein Ohr leitet und durch die Reflektion misst er halt das Volumen im Ohr. Ein anderes Beispiel wäre, ein einzelner Herzschlag eines Menschen ist so individuell, dass man es als biometrisches Merkmal verwenden kann.
Das ist jetzt alles irgendwie so ein bisschen Spezialbeispiele. Also die Standardbiometriesachen sind halt einfach so was wie Fingerabdruck, also was man aus Kriminalfällen kennt, wo der Mörder anhand von seinem Fingerabdruck auf der Tatwaffe identifiziert wird.
Netzhautscannen, sowas.
Wobei man natürlich unterscheiden muss bei diesen ganzen biometrischen Diskussionen, ist ob eine Verifikation, das heißt also ob quasi der Ausweis, der Personalausweis zu mir gehört mit den Daten, die drin gespeichert sind, oder ob es darum geht, mich aus einer bestimmten Menge zu identifizieren. Das heißt also die berühmte Verbrechererfahndung oder sowas. Das heißt also es gibt irgendwie eine Million Datensätze und da wird jetzt mit einem automatisierten Abgleich per Computer geguckt, ob jetzt mein Gesicht oder mein Fingerabdruck mit einem von diesen einer Million übereinstimmt.
Beziehungsweise, und da sind wir bei einem weiteren Thema dieser Sendung, wenn die biometrischen Daten meines Gesichtes irgendwo gespeichert sind in irgendeinem Rechner. Ich will jetzt eigentlich gar nicht wissen wo. Und es gibt eine Kamera wie zum Beispiel auf dem Hauptbahnhof in Mainz, wo es ja zwischen Oktober und Januar letzten Jahres und diesen Jahres so eine Art Fotofahnung gab. Das heißt alle Leute, die da rumgelaufen sind, von denen wurde Fotos gemacht und die wurden dann abgeglichen mit einer Datei, die man schon mal hat und kann dann rausfinden, ob der Bösewicht an sich die Treppe runterläuft.
Das ist ein sehr interessantes Schlagwort.
Und wenn ich zufälligerweise aussehe wie ein Bösewicht, habe ich ein Problem?
Na nicht ganz. Also was sie halt getestet haben, ist halt die Funktionsfähigkeit von Gesichtsidentifikationssoftware. Das heißt, sie haben halt über die Rolltreppe oder über die Treppe vom Hauptbahnhof ein paar Kameras gehängt und haben halt da getestet, was da so derzeit aktuell auf dem Markt ist, was sie halt dann für die Grenzübertritte benutzen wollen. Der interessante Punkt ist, dass die Ergebnisse bis jetzt noch nicht öffentlich gemacht wurden. Also der Versuch endete im März. Und sie haben eigentlich zugesagt, dass innerhalb von wenigen Wochen danach die Ergebnisse zu veröffentlichen. Jetzt haben wir gerade Anfang Mai und die Ergebnisse sind noch nicht da. Daraus schließen wir natürlich, dass die Ergebnisse relativ katastrophal ausgefallen sind.
Oder aber höchst interessant, wer sind eigentlich Sie oder die, die diese Daten...
In dem Fall war das das Bundeskriminalamt. Also die Behörden, die halt mit dem Grenzübertritt nachher zu tun haben und halt dieses System testen. Also auch hier wieder die Aufforderung, wenn halt jemand da schon eventuell nähere Informationen hat, irgendwie Ergebnisse kennt, daran sind wir auf jeden Fall durch das interessiert.
0331 77 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz zum Thema biometrische Vollerfassung. Wir hatten gerade eine kleine Einführung in das Thema Meldewesen. Warum hat der Mensch eigentlich einen Ausweis und Pass? Was ist die Personenkennzahl? Da werden wir nachher noch drauf eingehen. Und jetzt sind wir bei der Biometrie und so langsam fügt sich das Bild auch zusammen. Was passiert, wenn alle diese Daten irgendwann mal zusammen gemeinsam abgerufen werden? Was weiß der Staat über euch? Und wollt ihr, dass der Staat das überhaupt alles über euch weiß? Wir müssen auch noch ein bisschen mehr über die Biometrie reden, oder?
Genau, also wir waren ja gerade bei Gesichtsbild und im Zusammenhang mit elektronischen Reisepässen. Was halt jetzt der Punkt ist, also ab November gibt es ja jetzt auch noch die zweite Generation dieser elektronischen Reisepässe. Und da soll dann zusätzlich zu dem Gesichtsbild auch noch die Bilder von den zwei Zeigefingern aufgenommen werden. Und genau das Problem ist, dass halt damals bei der Einführung gesagt wurde, die Daten werden halt nur auf dem Reisepass gespeichert und halt nur zu dieser, was Frank schon gesagt hat, Verifikation, das heißt der 1 zu 1-Abgleich. Das heißt bin ich derjenige, dem der Ausweis gehört und was Herr Schäuble und der Bundesrat gerade angedeutet haben, was sie tun würden und was sie sehr gerne tun würden, dass sie halt diese Daten nicht nur auf den Ausweis speichern, sondern anders als sie damals geschworen haben, dass sie es tun werden jetzt auch in einer zentralen Datenbank. Das heißt, dann hat man halt genau das Problem, dass man halt, dass deine Fingerabdrücke gegen Tatortspuren abgeglichen werden können und somit halt Generalverdacht gegen die gesamte Bevölkerung besteht.
Hi, das ist aber nicht lustig.
Nee, das allerdings nicht.
Wir haben einen Anrufer aus Dänemark von Alexander. Guten Abend Alexander. Du rufst aus Dänemark an?
Ja, ich hör gerade den Livestream.
Oder gibt's einen Ort in Brandenburg, der Dänemark heißt, es wär mir neu.
Nee, nee, nee, das ist das Dänemark.
Was machst du in Dänemark?
Ich wohne hier.
Arbeite an einer Privatschule.
Aha, und für das Trinkl-Missich-Chaos-Radio.
Richtig.
Das ist aber schön.
Sehr lüblich. Äußerst lüblich, dann grüßen wir dich ganz besonders. Du wolltest was sagen zum Thema Personenkennziffer.
Ja, es geht nämlich darum, weil die Personenkennziffer, um nochmal wieder auf Kraut zurückzukommen, ist in den skandinavischen Ländern eigentlich überhaupt nichts Neues.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Das ist eigentlich in allen skandinavischen Ländern vertreten. Also in Dänemark setzen sich zusammen aus dem Geburtsdatum und vier Endziffern. Und jeder Bürger hat die in Dänemark.
Was bedeuten diese Endziffern, weißt du das?
Ich glaube, das sind nur Verifikationsziffern, ne Art.
Also fortlaufende Nummer, um halt die Personen eindeutig zu identifizieren.
Genau, wenn mehrere Leute an einem Tag geboren sind, was ja schon wahrscheinlich ist, dann seht man die halt durch.
Wir haben ja vorhin auch schon so ein bisschen gesagt, dass es ja durchaus auch Vorteile davon gibt, wenn man halt eine zentrale Personenkennziffer hat, aber dass es halt auch gerade in Deutschland halt deutlich Nachteile schon gegeben hat. Und ich meine, sowas wie 6 Millionen umgebrachte Union ist halt irgendwie schon als Nachteil zu sehen.
Meinst du denn, dass das generell in den skandinavischen Ländern ein anderes Herangehen daran ist? Man kennt ja zum Beispiel die Offenheit in Bezug auf Steuererklärungen und so. Denkst du, dass die Menschen in Skandinavien anders darüber denken?
Und dass wir einfach alle hier ein bisschen paranoid sind in Deutschland?
Ich glaube schon, dass es da einen Unterschied in der Mentalität gibt. Ich glaube, die sehen sind da ein bisschen ausnahm, was das angeht. Oder auf alle Fälle in Skandinavien sind da ein bisschen ausnahm, was das angeht.
Wobei es halt gerade in den skandinavischen Ländern ja auch ein ganz anderes Verhältnis gibt zwischen Bürger und Staat. Da sind halt auch die Behörden, die legen auch ihre Sachen offen. Das heißt, man kann also auch die Steuererklärung von Politikern einsehen und so was. Also das ist halt einfach alles ein bisschen transparenter, ein bisschen entspannter. Es ist vielleicht ein komischer Ausdruck in dem Zusammenhang. Aber es ist natürlich so klar, das ist halt einfach ein ganz anderes Verhältnis.
Ich meine, es hat natürlich auch durchaus seine Vorteile.
Also es bedeutet zum Beispiel, dass ich viele Behördengänge wirklich sparen kann.
Aber dafür braucht man ja keine Personenkennzahl. Das haben wir gestern schon mal andiskutiert, als wir uns über das Thema ein bisschen unterhalten haben, dass man ja durchaus mit digitalen Signaturen oder E-Government, wie es so schön heißt, die Sachen auch regeln kann, ohne halt eine eindeutige Personenkennziffer zu haben.
In Deutschland wird da gerade schon auch aufgeholt. Es gibt ja auch eine EU-Richtlinie, die sogenannte E-Government-Richtlinie, die ja auch die Mitgliedstaaten der EU dazu auffordert, ihre Verwaltung ein bisschen zu vereinheitlichen und zu straffen effizienter zu machen. Ich denke aber, dass die Skandinavier da ein bisschen voraus sind und dass auch gerade die Datenschutzbedenken in Deutschland hier diese Vereinheitlichung der Verwaltung beschränken.
Wie ist es denn mit dir? Hast du da ein gutes Gefühl dabei, in Dänemark, dass du da diese Personenkennziffer hast? Ist es in Ordnung da oder hättest du manchmal auch lieber, dass die Behörden vielleicht nicht so gut informiert sind?
Also manchmal hätte ich schon lieber, dass sie nicht ganz so gut informiert werden.
Weil es ist manchmal auch nicht nur bezüglich Behörden.
Also um mal jetzt mal zum Beispiel ein Beispiel zu nennen. Letztens habe ich zum Beispiel eine Bestellung übers Internet gemacht, bei einem dänischen Shop.
Und dann sollte ich natürlich, wie gesagt, meine Adressdaten alles angeben für die Lieferung.
Und als ich meine Telefonnummer eingegeben habe, dann hat irgendwie, wir wurden dann bei Datenbanken abgesucht und dann kam meine Adresse sofort zum Vorschein. Und das Formular war komplett ausgefüllt.
Also sie wussten mehr über dich als du geahnt hast, ja.
Das ist ja schon so ein bisschen erschreckend.
Sind dir eigentlich Fälle bekannt wie in den USA, wo wir ja die Social Security Number haben und doch so einiges an Betrug passiert? Sind dir solche Fälle aus Dänemark bekannt?
Also wir haben jetzt von dir sozusagen als Beispiel Personenkennziffer, die ja wie gesagt auch im Raum steht in Deutschland, dass das grundsätzlich ein paar praktische Vorteile hat, aber auf der anderen Seite es manchmal beängstigend ist, wenn man weiß, was alles über einen möglichen Datenbau steht. Dann Alexander, dann wünsche ich dir einen wunderbaren Tag und eine weitere schöne Woche in Dänemark. Und wir werden jetzt mal mit Martin telefonieren, der ist genauso alt wie du, nämlich 24 und kommt aus Deutschland. Hallo Martin, guten Abend. Du hast das gehört, was Alexander aus Dänemark gerade erzählt hat. Könntest du dir sowas in Deutschland vorstellen? Klingt sehr skeptisch. Warum?
Ach ja, das Datenbankverhalten, das ist mir ein bisschen zu suspekt. Es ist halt schade, die Behörden tun immer mehr den ganzen Staat bzw. die ganzen Bürger überwachen mit Kameras, mit Zugangskontrollen, mit diesem RFID. Aber wenn man mal vorschlägt, dass man vielleicht mal in den Behörden selber, in den Gebäuden, dass man da mal Kameras hinstellt und dass die Benutzer dann, weiß ich, vom Internet aus mal reinschauen können, was da so abgeht. Dann kommt die Tüte gleich an.
Ne, ne, ne, das geht nicht.
Wir können ja unsere Daten nicht veröffentlichen.
Da gehen die Datenschutzröse nicht ab. Aber auf der anderen Seite, Martin, wenn du dir nichts zur Schulden kommen lässt und braver Bürger bleibt, dir kann ja keiner was. Immer schön nur bei Grün über die Ampel gehen. Wir haben heute eine Menge Anrufer unter 0371, 7591 und 0. Unter anderem Lorenz. Lorenz ruft aus Helsinki an. Jetzt mach ich mir langsam ein kleines bisschen Sorgen. Guten Abend Lorenz, hallo grüß dich. Lorenz, weg ist er. Lorenz, vielleicht musst du hier, jetzt hab ich... Jetzt ist mein Fehler. Die Datenbank hier blödsinnig. Hi, der Dauß. Wir sind immer noch live in Potsdam-Babelsberg. Chaosradio 123. Es geht heute um die biometrische Vollerfassung. Ähm, warte mal, hier ist Lorenz. Nee, Lorenz ist... Wir klingeln Lorenz gerade noch mal an in der Zwischenzeit. Wir sind ein bisschen vom Thema abgekommen.
Ähm, nee, nee, wir waren schon mittendrin, das ist schon richtig. Also Personenkennziffer.
Vielleicht Konstanze, magst du noch mal was zu den SSNs, also zu den Social Security Nummern in Amerika sagen?
Diese Zahlversicherungsnummern.
Also wir haben vor allen Dingen im Jahr 2005, aber auch im Jahr 2006 hier wirklich viel in den normalen amerikanischen Zeitungen lesen können. Einfach schlicht, dass diese Nummern geklaut werden und auch verkauft werden. Also Kriminelle verkaufen diese Zahlen.
Das heißt, wenn irgendeine Behörde diese Nummer hat, dann ist es mehr oder weniger auch machbar, dass ich an diese Nummer rankomme. Wir müssen nicht mal dir die sozusagen abfressen.
Ja, es gibt halt verschiedene Wege. Also entweder wenn die Behörden zum Beispiel ihre Daten back-upen und per Tapes zu den Rechenzentren schicken, oder eben wenn sie nicht gesicherte Netze haben, dann kommen diese Daten eben abhanden. Und da sieht man besonders gerade in letzter Zeit viele Fälle von Betrugen mit diesen Zahlen. Also es ist in den USA weit verbreitet.
Also vor dem Betrug erstmal der Verlust der Daten. Und da hat man halt wirklich eigentlich im letzten Jahr so alle zwei Wochen, alle Woche irgendwie so riesengroße Schlagzeiten, dass irgendwie wieder 100.000 Kreditkartennummern oder SSNs, also Social Security Numbers, irgendwie abhanden gekommen sind.
Und das sind auch nur die Fälle, die bekannt werden. Man kann immer davon ausgehen, dass insbesondere die Behörden diese Social Security Numbers verlieren. Die sagen natürlich auch nur dann Bescheid, wenn mal wieder ein investigativer Journalist es aufgedeckt hat. Viele Fälle wären gar nicht bekannte.
Ja, es passiert. Also in Amerika gibt es das. Wir haben gerade gehört in Skandinavien gibt es das. Wie ist im Moment die Situation in Deutschland?
In Deutschland gibt es tatsächlich noch keine. Wir haben diese sogenannte Wirtschaftsidentifikationsnummer. Und die Diskussion um so eine Personenkennziffer kommt immer mal wieder auf. Das Spannende ist, es gibt derzeit auch Ansätze zu einem sogenannten zentralen Melderegister. Das ist auch nochmal ein wichtiger Begriff. Wir haben ja gehört, nach dem Krieg im Dritten Reich gibt es diese Meldestellen vor Ort. Da müssen wir vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen erklären, was da eigentlich passiert. Also wenn ich jetzt so einen Personalausweis beantrage, dann gehe ich da also hin und sage, hier bin ich. In der Regel habe ich ja schon einen Ausweis oder eine Geburtsurkunde oder irgendwas, nehme ich mit, dass ich schon nachweisen kann, wer ich bin. Dann gebe ich ein Foto ab.
Zwei muss man abgeben. Eins kriegst du auf den Ausweis, eins bleibt irgendwo da.
Gut, aber jetzt haben wir mittlerweile, ja genau, das ist eine interessante Frage. Und hergestellt werden ja die deutschen Personalausweise und Reisepässe von der Bundesdruckerei. Das ist die Firma oder eine Institution, die früher immer das Geld gedruckt hat in alle amtlichen Sachen für uns. Deswegen heißt die Bundesdruckerei, das war sozusagen der vertraute Betrieb, der also alles von Staatswegen gedruckt hat. Jetzt ist die Bundesdruckerei aber vor ein paar Jahren privatisiert worden, genau wie die Post und die Telekom sind die jetzt im Prinzip ein Privatunternehmen. Die haben eine wirtschaftlich, sag ich mal, turbulente Situation hinter sich, also mit Privatinvestoren nahezu pleite und ist jetzt eigentlich in eher dubiosen oder undurchsichtigen Besitzverhältnissen.
Und vor allem, sie standen vor der Insolvenz, also muss man sich mal klagen.
Eine Firma, die die kompletten Daten der Bundesbürger verwaltet, weil sie die ja auch irgendwo hindrucken müssen, die müssen ja irgendwo stehen, wird privat verwaltet und steht kurz vor der Insolvenz. Und irgendjemand kommt und sagt, ich hab genug Geld, ich kauf euch. Ei, das ist nicht schön.
Also generell darf die Bundesdruckerei eigentlich keine Daten weiter speichern, sondern die müssen ja Ausweise herstellen, schicken die dann wieder zu der Meldestelle zurück und danach müssen sie alles löschen. Das heißt, sie müssen nur quasi dem Bund Rechenschaft darüber abgeben, welche Ausweisnummern, das ist also die Reisepassnummer, die bei mir drauf steht, welche Pässe sie ausgegeben haben, damit man noch sehen kann, ok, ist der existierter jetzt wirklich, an wen ist der ausgegeben worden. Aber grundsätzlich werden diese Sachen eigentlich nicht gespeichert. Und jetzt ist es ein neuer Vorstoß, dass man sagt, ok, wenn wir schon jetzt so ein zentrales Melderegistern alles modernisieren und außerdem wollen wir nach Terroristen fahrenden und überhaupt, jetzt können wir das eigentlich auch schon zentral speichern. Wenn wir das schon alles digital erfassen, dann wollen wir das auch komplett digital speichern. Und eigentlich wollen wir auch so ein großes Google haben über die ganzen Daten. Wir lassen es zwar alles noch dezentral in Meldestellen überall. Noch? Noch, weil es ist ja eigentlich auch so vorgeschrieben, das wollen wir auch gar nicht anfassen. Aber wir wollen natürlich auch bundesweit darüber suchen. Das heißt also man, der sogenannte automatisierte Abruf von Daten. Das heißt also man kann dann nachschauen bei den bei den Meldemtern wirklich in einem automatisierten Verfahren. Auch ist da jemand gemeldet? Wenn ja, dann hätte ich gerne mal alle Daten inklusive Fotos. Und es ist eben was Neues und in Zukunft dann auch die Fingerabdrücke, wenn sie abgegeben worden sind.
Ich stehe da gerade rechtlich ein bisschen auf dem Schlauch. Es gibt in Deutschland eine Meldepflicht. Das heißt, ich bin verpflichtet, mich sozusagen als Bürger und Co. zu registrieren.
Du hast doch eine Ausweispflicht.
Ja, aber das heißt nicht, dass ich einen Ausweis habe. Ich muss den nicht immer mitführen, ich kann auch einen Reisepass haben.
Ja, du musst einen haben, also du musst einen von beiden haben. Also, einen Reisepass oder einen Personenausweis.
Was gibt es eigentlich, wenn ich so ein Ding nicht habe, oder wenn der abgelaufen ist? Das hatten wir letztens in einem Blumenlager gerade erklärt, was da passiert. Aber es ist nicht so, wie das man sagt. Naja, muss ich mal nachmachen.
Ich glaube, das ist eine Ordnungswidrigkeit. Aber das Problem ist einfach, dass man ohne Ausweis sehr wenig tun kann. Also du kannst halt keinen Konto öffnen, du kannst eigentlich keine Wohnung mieten, keine Versicherung abschließen. Das heißt, du bist halt einfach darauf angewiesen, so was zu haben. Sonst kannst du halt irgendwie nicht ordentlich leben in diesem Stadt.
Diese und viele andere Themen werden in dieser Sendung diskutiert. Die läuft jetzt gerade eine Stunde. Wir haben noch zwei weitere. Die Sendung heißt Chaos Radio, ist der Blumenlu mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Den gibt es immer jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Nur heute am ersten Mittwoch im Monat, weil letzte Woche gab es ein Fritz Spezial. Und damit ist es um 11.
Moon.
Es geht heute um die biometrische Vollerfassung. Bei uns sind Starbuck, Frank und Constanze vom CCC. Wir reden also darüber, was es bedeutet, wie viel Daten von einem gespeichert werden, was die Meldeämter alles überhaupt wissen und an euch auch die Frage, wie viel soll der Staat über euch wissen und was wisst ihr eigentlich, was der Staat über euch weiß. Wir hatten jetzt schon interessante Anrufe aus Dänemark, wo es so eine Personenkennzahl gibt. In Deutschland wird immer mal wieder darüber diskutiert, das hat Frank gerade erzählt. Und jetzt ist Lorenz wieder am Telefon. Lorenz ruft aus Helsinki an. Hallo Lorenz. Hallo, wieso haben wir plötzlich so viele Hörer in Skandinavien? Es freut mich ja total, aber...
Na, aber wahrscheinlich sind wir einfach schon ein bisschen weiter vorne dran.
Wohnst du dort oder bist du da auf Urlopole?
Seit wann?
Hast du schon eine PKZ?
Na, natürlich. Ohne geht's gar nicht. Aber ich wollte eigentlich noch was viel Interessantes erzählen, was uns letztlich passiert ist. Wo man sieht, warum man das, auch wenn der Staat eigentlich an nichts Böses tut, nicht direkt, warum man sowas eigentlich nicht haben will. Jetzt nützt sich in aller Frühe, also halb sieben, ein Anruf aufgebrachte Frau. Das Auto würde ihrem Weg stehen, unser Auto.
Woher weiß sie, dass das euer Auto ist?
Alles was man machen muss, ist bei der Polizei anrufen.
Bei uns ist das ja so, dass die Polizei dann sagt, wer das ist und auch wie ein Streifenwagen vorbeischickt.
Das heißt, wenn man einen Nachbarn hat, der einen nicht abkann und einen jeden Morgen wecken möchte, dann kann er das auf diese Weise tun?
Zum Beispiel oder Stalking oder auch das Stoff, weil dann noch ganz viele ein.
Damit sind wir bei den negativen Beispielen dieser biometrischen Vollerfassung, wo die Personenkennzahl auch mit da reingehört. Wie geht es dir damit, Lorenz, dass jeder weiß, wo du wohnst, wer du bist, welche Schuhgröße du hast und wieviel du Tellerbrötchen du isst?
Na ja, direkt beeinflussen tut es mich nicht, aber langfristig, wie gesagt, so Geschichten wie das hier, bei uns gehen ja noch ganz andere Sachen ab. Wir haben ja auch zum Beispiel hier das sämtlichen Personennahverkehr voll digitalisiert mit Profilerstellung und allem.
Konstanze, du hast gerade Wissenkenig. Kannst du das ein bisschen erläutern, was das bedeutet?
Na ja, man muss sich einfach vorstellen, dass die öffentlichen Personennahverkehr verkehre, da gibt es jetzt mehrere im europäischen Raum, halt mit diesen RFID, also funkelnde Ships, wieder ausgestattet sind, sodass man natürlich im Nachhinein diese Bewegungsprofile der Fahrgäste aufzeichnen kann. Und zunächst mal wurde es für logistische Zwecke benutzt, also um wegen meiner...
Wie viele Fahrgäste transportiert die U-Bahn in einer Stunde?
Um den Fahrplan zu optimieren, aber natürlich würde jeder Ermittler sich die Finger lecken nach diesen Daten. Und wenn diese Daten erst mal anfallen, ist es wie immer, dass nämlich die Ermittlungsbehörden plötzlich darauf zugreifen wollen, wenn irgendein beliebiger Straffall passiert.
Oder aber ich sag dann in zweifels Fall, dann fahr ich nicht mehr mit der Bahn, dann fahr ich mit dem Auto.
Na, ist auch nicht so eine gute Idee, wegen der Maut und der...
Fahr unter einer Mautbrücke durch, die weiß, wo mein Nummernschild ist. Ja, naja, gut, okay. Chaosradio auf Fritz Lorenz, auf jeden Fall dir vielen Dank für den Anruf für die kurzen, nicht sehr amüsanten Einblicke in das Leben in Finnland. Wir wünschen dir einen beruhigenden, entspannten Tag.
Und geh früh schlafen, weil du wirst morgen wieder geweckt werden von deiner Nachbarin.
Und freundliche Nachbarn. 0331 70 97 110. Wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich über euch wissen? Chaosradio auf Ritzen, Mittwochabend kurz nach 11. Am Telefon ist Sven aus Köpenick, der interessante Post von seiner Behörde bekommen hat. Hallo Sven, guten Abend. Wie geht's dir denn?
Jo, gut soweit.
Gut soweit, dann erzähl mal was passiert ist.
Also es ist kein solanger Herde, weil jetzt vor bis zu über eine Woche, aber ich bin unfriedlich, Entschuldigung.
Alles gut, alles gut.
Jedenfalls von der Behörde so ein Einschreiben gekriegt, dass ich angeblich nicht im Besitz eines gültigen Personalspreises bin und auch kein Reisepass und so. Und dass ich unbedingt je nach beantragen müsste, sonst wo die unten stehen, halt irgendwie was von Geldbuße bis zu 1000 Euro und so weiter.
Das ist ja interessant.
Aber du hast sowas, oder?
Naja, sicherlich. Also ich sag mal, mit 31 Jahren durchs Leben zu kommen, mit Führerschein, anderen dran, ohne Personalausweise, ist ein bisschen schlecht.
Und einer von denen ist auch noch gültig, oder?
Ja, naja, sogar bis 2012.
Also ein klassischer Behörden-Turm.
Genau, dann war ich dann auch gleich munter hin. Dann hab ich nach der Frau gefragt, die hier drauf steht, war dann nicht da, aber die hat mich dann halt an eine Kollegin weiterverwiesen und ja, hat so gesagt, naja, dann ist meine Kollegin vom Fehlerunterlaufen. Dann hab ich so gesagt, naja, also war ich schon ein bisschen sauer und hab dann halt auch gemeint, naja, so eine Kollegen sollen irgendwann mal die Vorratdatenspeicherung verwalten.
So viel zum Thema, eure Daten sind da sicher, uns passiert euch.
Noch mal eine kurze Nachfrage, die Daten, also es stimmt wirklich über einen, also sie haben dich nicht falsch geschrieben, irgendwie nicht im Video eine Adresse verwechselt.
Vor allen Dingen bin ich vor anderthalb Jahren ungefähr nach Kürbini gezogen und da hab ich ja auf dem Ausweis ja den Umzug, also den Luftkleber raufgekriegt. Und naja, ich mein, und dass wir nach anderthalb Jahren, wenn ich angeblich, wenn die Kollege noch da irgendwie meinte, mich da irgendwie nicht eins tragen zu wollen in diesem Verzeichnis da, dann fängt das auch schon, also wie gesagt, die Leute auch jetzt um mich anschreien zu können. Das ist die Logik alleine schon, mich anschreien zu können, auch wenn ich gar nicht irgendwo wohnlich gemeldet sein kann, weil ich ja dann auch wieder einen Personenausweis vorzeigen müsste.
Also das finde ich auch auf jeden Fall krass. Also ich hab so eine Geschichte auch noch nie vorher gehört, dass halt irgendwie das Amt einen anschreibt, dass man einen Personenausweis beantragen soll.
Aber es gibt ja auch immer die Geschichten, dass Leute Post bekommen und sagen, sie sind ja übrigens tot, bitte schicken sie ihre Lohnsteuerkarte wieder zu.
Gehst du dann nochmal hin? Oder ist das jetzt für dich abgegessen?
Nee, wie gesagt, ich war da und sie hat sich dann halt nochmal zweimal entschuldigt. Und hat sich gefreut, dass ich da so schnell gekommen bin und es geklärt hab.
Also es wäre auf jeden Fall mal interessant zu wissen, ob das halt öfter passiert oder ob das jetzt ein Ausnahmefall ist und wie sie das begründet, dass das passiert ist. Weil das ist irgendwie echt ein unglaubliches Ding, finde ich.
Aber ist das nicht auch ein bisschen beruhigend? Also ich meine, nehme ich mal im Ernst, das einfach so, das einfach nicht so 100% funktioniert. Der Staat denkt für dich mit.
Beruhigend, dass du Post kriegst?
Dass es nicht 100% funktioniert.
Möchtest du bitte deinen Ausweis neu machen? Wenn du sowieso einen hast, dann finde ich nicht sehr beruhigend.
Vor allem hier steht da drauf, dass ich, kann man ja so was ankreuzen, oder haben die ja was angekreuzt, ob der noch Gültigkeit hat oder eben ob ich überhaupt den besitze. Und dann ist hier angekreuzt, sie sind nicht im Besitz eines Personals.
Hast du das schreiben noch? Also kannst du uns das irgendwie zukommen lassen?
Schick mal eine Mail an Chaosradio CCC.de, dann können wir dir auch eine Faxnummer sagen.
CCC.de, da sind auch alle anderen Mails von euch, wenn ihr Fragen habt oder Kommentare, sind gut aufgehoben.
Dann haben wir auch eine Faxnummer dann.
Also weil das ist definitiv interessant und da wollen wir auch mal danach haken.
Danke für den Aufsehen, tschüss und keine Sorge, Vaterstadt guckt nach dir. Die gucken übrigens auch nach, ob du brav um halb 12 ist, Licht ausmachst großer. Okay, also wir reden heute im Blumen über die biometrische Vollerfassung, was für ein hässliches Wort. Wir haben es jetzt schon ein bisschen geklärt, wir sind jetzt dabei, warum es Ausweise gibt und ein Meldewesen, was biometrische Daten eigentlich sind. Also sowas wie Fingerabdrücke und Größe und die Stimme und mein Gesicht und so weiter und so fort. Und wir sind jetzt bei der Diskussion, bislang könnte man ja sagen, ja, sollen sie machen. Was kann eigentlich damit alles passieren? Und wo ist das Problem? Warum regen sich alle darüber auf?
Also der große Wunsch nach vor allem nach den Fingerabdrücken ist eigentlich in den 70er Jahren in den Hochzeiten der RAF aufgekommen. Das war der damalige Generalbundesanwalt Bubak, der gesagt hat, also eigentlich ist jetzt mal gerade die richtige Zeit, dass wir mal komplett von der ganzen Bevölkerung die Fingerabdrücke erfassen. So und es war aber damals schon klar, eben auf diesem Basieren auf diesem anderen Urteil, dass es also eben diese Personenkennziffer nicht geben darf. Also so ganz einfach wird es nicht. Und man hat auch damals schon gemerkt, das wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht klappen. Das ist mit der Verfassung nicht vereinbar. Und wir würden damit ja die ganze Bevölkerung im Prinzip wie Kriminelle behandeln. Das heißt, wenn wir jeden antanzen lassen und dann so richtig klassisch ist das aber jetzt übrigens auch noch nicht mit der Verfassung vereinbar.
Es ist jetzt auch noch nicht.
Aber ab November werden auf jeden Fall von jedem Reisepass, den wir beantragen, die Fingerabdrücke abgeben, wenn nicht noch ein Wunder passiert.
Das heißt, wenn ich klein bin, verlängere ich meinen Pass vor November und habe dann noch zumindest für ein paar Jahre Ruhe.
Wichtig war es hier, 2005 haben sie ja den ersten Generation des E-Passes eingeführt mit Gesichtserkennung. Da haben wir es schon gesagt, ihr holt euch vor November noch einen neuen Pass. Der ist zehn Jahre gültig. Ihr könnt trotzdem weiter in die USA einreisen und überall rumfahren. Das Gleiche gilt natürlich jetzt auch. Und wenn ihr eure Fingerabdrücke nicht abgeben wollt oder noch nicht abgeben wollt, auf jeden Fall vor November noch einen neuen Pass holen. Das Problem ist, das könnt ihr nicht machen, wenn ihr in einen der Meldeämter geht, die an diesem Test derzeit teilnehmen. Also es gibt halt jetzt schon einen vorläufigen Test.
Gibt es eine Liste irgendwo, wer dabei ist?
Also es sind von den 5700 Meldeämtern, die wir haben, 50. Also wir wissen von Potsdam, von Bremen, von Hamburg. Die sind wohl gut verteilt über die Bundesrepublik.
Vielleicht hört ihr jemand zu aus Potsdam?
Genau.
Du kannst einfach mal berichten, wie das so war. Und hat sich jetzt gerade in den letzten Zeiten einen Reisepass geholt und musste deinen Fingerabdruck abgeben. Das wäre natürlich super, wenn noch mal jemand anrufen kann, auch mal berichten kann.
Also was halt der Fall ist, dass man, wenn man halt in solchen Meldeämtern, also wenn man dort seinen Ausweis, seinen Pass beantragt, dann kommt man halt nicht darum, seinen Fingerabdruck abzugeben, obwohl man halt eigentlich ja die Wahl hätte und die Frist noch nicht abgelaufen ist. Aber dort ist es dann halt verpflichtend. Man kriegt irgendwie fünf Euro Rabatt, was ich irgendwie echt eine sehr lächerliche Summe für die Preisgabe irgendwie sehr persönlicher Daten finde. Und man kommt halt wie gesagt nicht drum rum.
Hast du gerade irgendwie, bis du über den Satz gefallen, Star Wars?
Ja, ich wollte noch irgendwas sagen, aber...
Pass auf, du suchst deinen Satz. Wir haben quasi die Telefonleiste immer voll. Ihr könnt auch gerne weiter anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über die biometrische Vollerfassung mit der etwas polemischen Frage hinten dran. Wie viel soll der Staat eigentlich überhaupt über euch wissen? Und was weiß der Staat über euch alles? Am Telefon ist Marco aus Eberswalde. Guten Abend Marco. Grüße dich herzlich. Hast du schon mal über solche Geschichten wie Personenkennziffer und Fingerabdruck in deinem Ausweis und sowas wie dein Handy ist trackbar und man weiß wo du bist. Hast du darüber schon mal nachgedacht? Ist das ein Thema an deinem Leben?
Weil ich auch viel drüber gelesen hab schon. Und ich bin der Meinung, wenn es erst mal durch ist, dann ist es halt legalisiert, weil ich bin der Meinung, der Staat kann jetzt schon jeden kontrollieren, den er nur kontrollieren möchte. Und er weiß auch alles.
Also da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. Kann man das so sagen? Kann man das so quasi?
Also was wolltest du mit kontrollieren?
Ja, die Möglichkeiten da sind ja, FNF kontrollieren, Telefon abhören und wenn man jetzt weiß, was vor 20, 30 Jahren schon in der Abwehrtechnik möglich war, dann wissen wir mal, wo wir heute sind, ob der Pazialitis ist oder weiß nicht, was noch alles gibt, aber ich bin mir sicher, dass noch viele sagen, gibt es noch einen, wo überhaupt nicht Bescheid ist.
Na, auf jeden Fall halt also Mobiltelefon. Also Handy ist halt so das klassische Beispiel zur Personenortung und jetzt mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung bzw. mit der Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Was bedeutet, man muss sich vielleicht nochmal erklären, das ist durch, dass die Kommunikationsdaten, die du per Handy, per Telefon oder per Internet gemacht hast, sechs Monate gespeichert werden.
Genau, also was sie jetzt speichern ist, wer mit wem wann telefoniert hat.
Und auch Unterhuch.
Sondern stell dich mal vor, jeder hat jetzt diesen Horsway, jeder, der Staat hat alles bei ihm.
Wie er aussieht, wie er heißt, wie alt, wie groß, wie schwer. Ähm, angenommen, da würde jetzt jemand versuchen, eine Demonstration oder so was zu machen, ne?
Wo der Staat absolut was dagegen hat.
Dann gibt es da jetzt keine Ladestiche vom Staat, gar nichts Bohres, aber das kommt gar nicht dazu. Also das ist halt die Vollkontrolle. Die Illegale sieht ja Vollkontrolle, wo es dann irgendwann geht.
Genau, also allein wenn man weiß, dass man beobachtet wird, ändert man halt auch sein Verhalten. Das heißt, man hat zwar das Recht, theoretisch auf Demonstration zu gehen und seinen Willen gegen zum Beispiel die Regierung auszudrücken, aber wenn man halt sich gewahr sein muss, dass man auf jeden Fall dann auch mit Namen und Anschrift irgendwie erkannt wird, dann überlegt man sich das halt doch nochmal zweimal.
Und da geht es gar nicht um das Angst hat darum, aber wiederum kann man auch sagen, es wird auch physisch gesendet.
Also die Kontrolle liegt ja nicht nur bei den Personen, sondern die Kontrolle liegt ja auch in den Medien.
Ja, aber Freunde, es bringt uns zu der wirklich interessanten Frage, wo führt das alles hin und wie verhalten wir uns dabei? Wenn man jetzt darüber nachdenkt, dass man quasi auch als Journalist möglicherweise nicht mehr das laut sagen kann und das kommunizieren kann, was man eigentlich denkt, weil man Angst hat, dass die irgendwie aufs Dach steigen, sage ich mal ganz vorsichtig, wo führt das hin und bauen wir jetzt hier gerade eine ziemlich schwarze Utopie oder ist das realistisch, was wir hier machen?
Das ist leider zu realistisch.
Also ich würde dich gerne mal fragen, wenn du mit dir zu aufzählst und sagst, du bist ohnehin schon zu bewacht, würde dich dann jetzt noch stören, wenn zum Beispiel bei einer Verkehrswiedrigkeit deinerseits noch deine Fingerabdrücke von dem Streifenpolizisten genommen werden?
Ja, prinzipiell würde es mich schon stören, aber es geht natürlich darum, auch mal meine Fingerabdrücke zu haben. Sondern ob die ganze Bundesregierung, die ganzen deutschen Bewohner diese Fingerabdrücke abgeben müssen.
Also siehst du, das ist gar nicht unbedingt für dich selbst bezogen, sondern mehr als allgemein das Phänomen, was du als Ungut betrachtest?
Ich denke mal, viele denken, ja, die Politiker wollen ja nur das Gute für uns, so ist es aber nicht. Ich bin der Meinung, dass es eine große Institution gibt. Und die sind halt davon aus, diesen totalen, total nicht totalientären Staat jetzt übertrieben. Aber die volle Kontrolle, und es wird soweit kommen, es ist einfach so. Und früher oder später wird es soweit gehen, da wird jeder seinen Chip unterholt bekommen. Und dann kommst du halt damit rein, wo du einkaufen gehst, dann hast du vielleicht, wenn es geht, noch deine, wo du damit befahlst, ne? Und wenn ich weiß, war die Schweiz, wenn es nicht soweit ging, die könnte oder hätte so theoretisch die ganzen Banken runterfahren können und könnte hätte auf diesem System umstellen können schon. Und früher oder später wird es kommen, und wer das nicht macht, der ist halt raus.
Wir machen mal folgendes Marco, das ist zwar eine ziemlich düstere Prognose, die du da ziehst, trotz alledem, lass dir deinen Tag nicht versauen. Und an dich gilt dasselbe wie an alle anderen auch. Pass auf, der Staat weiß, ob du um halb zwölf das Licht ausmachst. Danke für deinen Anruf. Blue Moon, Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 123. Wir reden über biometrische Vollerfassung. Wir sind jetzt wieder mal dabei, was der Staat alles an Daten über uns sammelt. Wollen wir das eigentlich? Wir hatten gerade das Thema elektronischer Reisepass und welche Meldeämter neben daran teilnehmen. Was passiert da eigentlich? Am Telefon ist Oliver. Oliver, welches richtig mitbekommen, hat heute einen Pass beantragt oder gekriegt. Hallo Oliver.
Ich hab heute meinen neuen biometrischen Reisepass bekommen.
Doch, der Chip ist drinnen.
Der ist definitiv drinnen. Das siehst du an dem Zeichen vorne drauf. Da ist so ein symbolisierter Chip drauf.
Das ist ein kleines vierjähriges Zeichen mit einem Kreis in der Mitte. Direkt auf der Decke des Passes.
Na ja, es war für mich heute ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Ich bin das erste Mal Besitzer eines richtigen Reisepasses sozusagen. Keine Vorläufigen. Und bin mir jetzt auch bewusst, dass jetzt alle was über mich wissen. Also die, die es auf jeden Fall wissen wollen. Es ist schon ein komisches Gefühl. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, was der Vorredner alles erzählt hat, weil es mir ein bisschen komisch rüber kam. Aber ich finde es so zu sagen, na ja, dann ist es halt irgendwann schon ziemlich merkwürdig. Und ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum man... Also ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich abgefahren und eigentlich ziemlich schräg, dass das wahrscheinlich demnächst dann vielleicht doch so sein wird. Und es kotzt mich eigentlich auch so ein bisschen an, weil ich frage es ihn wirklich, wo geht das irgendwann hin?
Wo geht das hin, ist die eine Frage, das können wir natürlich nur spekulieren. Viel interessanter ist der Status Quo, über den man reden kann. Du hast heute so einen Pass gekriegt, da ist so ein Chip drin. Vielleicht können wir ganz kurz nochmal zu wampassen, was da drin steht. Dein Name, dein Familienname, welcher Statin ausgestellt hat, eine Passnummer, bist du Männchen, Weibchen, Geburtsdatum, wenn der Pass abläuft und dein biometrisches Passfoto und Fingerabdrücke, sind die schon drin? Okay, diese Daten sind bis jetzt irgendwo beim Melde-Register, Meldeamt hinterlegt.
Früher waren es Karteikarten, die Klassischen. Deswegen mussten sie auch zwei Fotos abgeben. Sogar eins kam rein und eins kam in die Kartei. Heutzutage, ich glaube, man muss wirklich nur noch eins abgeben. Das würde ich mir eingescanen.
Ich würde eins abgeben.
Das ist doch ein Vorteil, total toll.
Jetzt mal weiter gespannt. Okay, jetzt sind diese Daten in diesem Pass. Jetzt komme ich auf die dumme Idee, in einen Supermarkt zu gehen, eine Tafel Schokolade mir zu nehmen und leider vergessen zu bezahlen, was man ja nicht macht. Hat die Polizei diese Daten dann auch sofort, wenn die bei Meldeamt liegen? Und damit sind wir ja bei dem Punkt, über den wir eigentlich reden.
Genau. Wenn jetzt die Polizei von einem Supermarktbetreiber bekommt, bekommt sie jetzt die Videoaufzeichnung, wo sie dich gefilmt haben. Und was jetzt sozusagen das Albtraum-Szenario ist, dass sie dieses Videobild nehmen und gegen eine große Datenbank laufen lassen mit allen Gesichtsbildern von allen 80 Millionen Leuten, die wir in Deutschland haben, die dann ihre Bilder abgegeben haben, die sind biometrisch vermessen. Das heißt, wir können anhand von dieser Videoaufzeichnung dann sehen, ah, der war's. Fotofahndung, genau. Und dann steht dann die Polizei bei dir vor der Tür, guck nochmal, ja, der ist es wirklich. Und zack, so schnell geht es. Das Gleiche ist natürlich auch, was wir schon gesagt haben, bei einer Demonstration. Das heißt, ich kann eine Teilnehmerliste machen von allen Leuten auf der Demonstration, wenn ich die Kameras geschickt genug aufstelle und die technische Entwicklung noch ein kleines bisschen weiter ist, als sie jetzt ist. Wobei wir also wirklich sagen müssen, wir sind nicht mehr ganz so weit. Also es ging dann ziemlich schnell bei der automatischen Bilderkennung in den letzten Jahren. Das ist also im Prinzip das Horror-Szenario, was wir haben. Und sag ich mal, die Light-Version davon, in Anführungszeichen. Das ist nämlich genau das, warum diese ganze Diskussion jetzt gerade hochgekommen ist. Da geht es um den Abruf und um den Vergleich von diesem Personalausweisfoto für Ordnungswidrigkeiten, nämlich vor allem, um es zu schnell fahren. Oder um rote Ampeln, also um Verkehrsordnungswidrigkeiten, wo man also nur das Bild hat vom Fahrer. Und der sagt dann, ich hab mein Auto verliehen, keine Ahnung.
Ich war es nicht.
Ich war es nicht. Und dann geht es darum, diese Bilder abzugleichen. Und deshalb gab es bisher auch schon einigen Streit, ob das überhaupt rechtens ist, ob das, sag ich mal, eine, das ist ja schon eine Datenschutzproblematische Sache, wenn ich diese Fotos abgleiche. Und ob so eine einfache Verkehrsordnungswidrigkeit jetzt reicht, um quasi diesen ziemlich massiven Datenschutz, den wir bisher noch hatten, diese Datentrennung dann aufzubrechen für den Zweck. Und da ist jetzt im Prinzip auch, wo der Streit sozusagen losgegangen ist, wo die Diskussion eigentlich öffentlich wurde da drum, dass jetzt die SPD gesagt hat, Moment, das ist uns doch ein bisschen zu viel. Und so war das jetzt nicht gemeint. Und da müssen wir jetzt nochmal drüber reden. Und das ist eigentlich genau der Stand, den wir gerade jetzt haben in der politischen Diskussion.
Wenn ich mich da kurz einmelde, wann wird dieser Stand aufgehoben und wird komplett neu verarbeitet? Und man weiß ja nie, wer dann irgendwann mal vielleicht doch Macht bekommt. Und es gibt ja so irgendwelche science-pitschen Filme, die das ja alles beschrieben haben, wo dann irgendwann vielleicht dieser Chip irgendwann im Gehirn drinne sitzt. Und dann ist ja die Frage, nimmt man uns das Gehirn oder am besten noch gleich die DNA, um zu gucken, ist der irgendwann noch existent, man hat ja Krankheiten, man muss man ausrotten oder was auch immer. Ich meine, das ist natürlich weit hergeholt, aber das geht mir ziemlich alles auf den Sack. Also das kann doch alles nicht mehr wahr sein, dass der Staat nur noch alles wissen will über die Bürger. Also wenn der Staat so viel Angst hat vor uns, ich meine, das ist ja schrecklich, also dann tun die Leute mir da echt ein bisschen leid. Also es geht mir echt, irgendwo ist ja mal eine Grenze oder nicht. Ich meine, es gab sowas mal, das hieß, glaube ich, DDR oder so. Dann hätten die auch ja nicht sagen müssen, vernichtet die Stasi, dann hätten die doch einfach sagen können, ey Leute, super, ihr habt's drauf, dann lasst uns weitermachen. Dann hätten sie den ganzen Scheiß sparen können und hätten wir gleich weitermachen können, also bitte. Also irgendwo ist ja mal eine Grenze oder nicht.
Das ist genau der interessante Punkt, dass wir halt inzwischen hier soweit oder eigentlich schon deutlich weiter sind, als die Stasi oder die DDR damals halt gewesen ist. Und irgendwie heutzutage regt sich halt nicht wirklich jemand rüber auf.
Niemand mehr und das geht mir langsam auch auf den Sack. Aber es ist wieder eine wirkliche Opposition, die da mal sagt. Moment mal, also hallo. Irgendwie machen alle mit und sagen, ja super, naja gut, okay, wir können uns halt nicht mehr wehren. Und auch die Bevölkerung hat das Gefühl, sagt, naja gut, okay, ist halt so. Und vielleicht doch sicherer, weil dann können wir eben auch alle Kriminellen sofort am besten erschießen oder irgendwo wegschweren. Also irgendwo ist das alles echt langsam, echt nicht mehr schön.
Du regst dich auf. Also ich meine, das ist doch schon mal der erste Schritt irgendwie. Es gibt halt wirklich langsam zu, also zunehmend Leute, die halt jetzt wirklich sagen, es ist jetzt echt mal genug und so geht das nicht weiter. Und genau das muss jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen vermehrt an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht werden.
Also ich meine gerade so, auch die Ehemaligen, die der Erdbürger wissen, aber das heißt beobachtet zu werden und nicht mehr klar zu denken. Und wenn die dann irgendwann anfangen zu sagen, muss man auch zu denken, scheiße, und deswegen gibt es jetzt hier irgendwie einen Bau oder so. Also das kann doch alles nicht mehr sein, aber selbst da regt sich auch keiner mehr auf und sagt, im Gegenteil, das wird ja fast noch verharmlos. Und dann muss man auch zu denken, ja so schlimm war es doch gar nicht, war doch eigentlich ganz nett. Und da wusste man wenigstens lieber zu leben haben und da wusste man mal auf die Toilette gehen sollen. Also ich finde es langsam wirklich nicht mehr feierlich. Und deswegen macht man auch langsam ein bisschen Angst. Man weiß auch gar nicht, wie weit die schon mittlerweile sind. Und jetzt war ja unser Angie wieder, kuschelt ja wieder mit Georgie da ein bisschen rum und zu gucken, was wir jetzt noch weitermachen können. Also irgendwo ist echt einfach mal Grenze und kann nur hoffen, dass irgendwann mal Politiker wach werden und sagen, Leute, stopp, also das geht nicht. Aber dann, ich meine, ob das unser ehemaliger Innenminister war, unser jetztherer Innenminister ist, die drücken ja vollkommen aus bei dem Thema und sagen, na super geil. Also irgendwie, also es ist schon beängstigend, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Und da kommen einem so echt komische Filme in den Kopf, wo man sagt, na eben, so gab's gerade schon mal und so, pff, dann haben wir es halt wieder. Und vielleicht brauchen wir Deutschen jetzt auch, ich weiß es ja nicht.
Nein, nein.
Die Sache ist, ich finde ja, du fasst das sehr schön zusammen. Ich musste darüber nachdenken, als die ganzen Zeitungen und die Fernsehsender in Deutschland über diesen Film das Leben der anderen berichtet haben, als sie jetzt eben zu den Oscars in Amerika ja wieder in der Presse waren. Alle haben darüber berichtet. Aber irgendwie niemand hat diesen Bezug zu der heutigen Realität gesehen, der einfach klar da ist. Oder in deinem Rechner.
Oder in meinem Rechner, ganz kurz. Stichwort Bundestrojaner. Oder sie gucken sich an, mit wem du telefoniert hast. Stichwort Vorratsdaten-Speichel.
Also auf jeden Fall wissen sie gerade, dass du derjenige bist, der jetzt gerade bei Furz angerufen hat.
Ich hoffe doch, dass das sehr viele Leute wissen, weil es sollen ja auch viele Leute hören. Damit würde ich jetzt kurz sozusagen von Oliver zu Stefan kommen. Oliver, dir vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Wir können zwei Sachen festhalten. Zum einen ist es ganz wichtig, dass man den Schnabel aufmacht und sagt, das passt mir hier nicht, was hier gerade passiert. Auch wenn du dich jetzt nicht gegen deinen neuen Reisepass werden kannst mit dem Chip drin. Aber sich sozusagen zu Hause hinzusetzen, die Nachmittagsberieselungssendung im Fernsehen anzumachen, ist eigentlich nicht der Weg, den man gehen sollte. Oliver, deswegen dir einen schönen Abend und denke dran, der Staat guckt, ob du halb zwölf Licht ausmachst. 0331-70-97-1199 Blue Moon mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf Fritz, Ausgabe 123. Wir reden über biometrische Vorerfassung und ihr seht, es ist nicht eine rein technische Diskussion, obwohl wir schon viele Einblicke in die Technik bekommen haben, sondern vor allen Dingen auch eine gesellschaftspolitische Diskussion, die uns alle angeht. Zum Beispiel auch dich, lieber Stefan aus Lichtenberg. Guten Abend.
Ja, schönen guten Abend. Erstmal wurde ich jetzt mit meinen Vorrednern schon eine ganze Menge vorweggenommen. Ich wollte aber noch mal was Geschichtliches erzählen. Das hatte ich nämlich mal irgendwo gelesen, weil meines Wissens nach, nachdem die Deutschen unter dem NS-Regime in Norwegen oder Finnland eingeritten sind, haben die dort es eigentlich ziemlich schnell geschafft, in einem Monat fast sämtliche Juden zusammenzutrommeln. Und das lag meines Wissens daran, dass dort die angemeldeten Radios, die Karteien der jüdischen Bevölkerung, einfach separat aufbewahrt wurden. Das zeigt alleine schon mal, wie gefährlich es eigentlich sein kann, irgendwo von jemanden irgendwelche Daten zu speichern. In meinen Augen gibt es auch leider nicht wirklich Sicherheit, dass wir in Deutschland unsere Daten jetzt getrennt derzeit abliegen müssen, weil, gut, in meinen Augen, wenn die Datenbanken einigermaßen die selbe Stützchen haben, ist es sogar noch effektiver, diese getrennten Datenbanken abzufragen, zeitgleich als eine Zentrale. Also ich hab auf jeden Fall schneller das Ergebnis da.
Du meinst, weil man nicht so lange sucht in den Daten, oder was?
Naja, ich hab ja kleinere Datensätze, die ich durchsuche. Und wenn ich jetzt nun an, sag ich mal, 1000 Datenbanken gleichzeitig diese Suchanfrage losschicke, werde ich auch entsprechend schneller das Ergebnis haben, weil alle 1000 gleichzeitig meine Suchanfrage bearbeiten.
Also, ich meine mal, da hat Starbucks eine Meinung dazu.
Sehr passend zu dem Thema ist halt die Terrorismus-Datenbank, wo halt genau auch dieses irgendwie ich bin Islamist-Fleck drin steht. Das heißt irgendwie, wir sind halt einfach schon wieder so weit, wie wir damals gewesen sind.
Also, die hieß eigentlich Antiterror-Datei. Da wurde ja auch ewig drüber geredet, aber da hat sich der Bundesminister einfach mal durchgesetzt.
Also, bei der Antiterror-Datei haben wir natürlich auch verschiedene Probleme. Das eine ist tatsächlich auch diese Stigmatisierung oder Fassung von Merkmalen über eine Person, wo die eigentlich auch gar nicht, ja, sie können nicht wirklich Auskunft, man kann schon Auskunft bekommen, glaube ich. Aber es ist einfach, diese Daten werden erst mal gesammelt, egal ob sie jetzt stimmen oder nicht. Das heißt, jede Behörde macht da quasi Notizzettel ran über all ihre Erkenntnisse, die sie haben über eine Person. Das eigentliche Problematische ist aber die Zusammenführung von Polizei und Geheimdiensten dabei. Das sind also auch wirklich komplett getrennte Sachen, auch aus gutem Grund wieder aus dem dritten Bereich, den wir da hatten. Dass man also sagt, Geheimdienste und Polizei dürfen nicht zusammenarbeiten, in dem Sinne, dass sie die Daten nicht, ihre Erkenntnisse nicht austauschen dürfen. Und dieses wird mit sehr gemeinsamen Detail natürlich auch wieder aufgeweicht und zunichtig gemacht.
Wir haben schlicht ein Trennungsgebot. Also es ist verfassungsrechtlich bei uns vorgegeben, dass Geheimdienste und Ermittlungsbehörden eben nicht die Daten austauschen dürfen.
Das war ein kleiner Exkurs zur Terrordatei.
Ja und wo ich mir halt auch Gedanken mache, ist halt mit Sammeln von Informationen. Die Frage ist auch, inwieweit bringen ja natürlich Informationen, was jetzt z.B. Stichwort Vorratsdatenspeicherung auf dem Telefon gespricht oder so. Was bringt es mir quasi, wenn man keine Ahnung, wie irgendwas angeklagt wird. In 5 Monaten sitzt man dann vor einem Beamten dort, der einen dann fragt so, Sie haben vor 5 Monaten mit Personen so oder so geredet. Was haben Sie damals mit denen besprochen? Was bringen denn diese Daten?
Du darfst nicht mehr von dieser Unschuldsvermutung ausgehen. Du musst dann quasi erstmal beweisen, dass du nicht gewesen bist.
Naja, das führt ja auch wieder zu diesem Beispiel, was halt gerade vielleicht auch dann zum Beispiel elektronische Reiseteste oder auch irgendwann elektronische Ausweise, wo es unbedingt unter Umständen hingehen wird, die dann vielleicht auch durch irgendwelche Lesegeräte auslesbar sind und Bewegungsprofiler mittelbar sind. Dort gibt es ein schönes Szenario, was von sowohl Befürwortern als auch Gegner von dieser RFID-Technik verwendet wird, nämlich...
Das sind diese Funkchips, die RFID-Chips?
Genau. Totes Kind liegt im Wald und daneben liegt eine Packung von Schoko-Regeln. Und kommt diese Verpackung jetzt von demjenigen, der das Kind dorthin gelockt hat und umgebracht hat? Oder liegt diese Packung nur zufällig da? Zumindest derjenige, der sie dann gekauft hat, wenn es dann zurückverfolgbar ist, wird verdächtigt werden.
Nur ist diese Situation natürlich sehr konstruiert, aber man kann sowas auf alle möglichen anderen Situationen natürlich auch umdenken. Zum Beispiel, du hast irgendwann mal ein Mietwagen genommen, weil dein Auto ist kaputt gegangen, bist von A nach B gefahren und dieses Auto taucht dann irgendwo mal wieder auf und in diesem Auto ist irgendwie ein Kaugummi geblieben, der ist von dir. Und dann muss man die Geschichte einfach nur weiter denken. Stefan, pass auf, wir müssen jetzt kurz Nachrichten machen. Und dann, wir haben jetzt mit ganz vielen Leuten geredet, die gesagt haben, sie finden es nicht gut und sie finden es nicht okay, was man alles machen kann. Wir haben Jens am Telefon und Jens will glaube ich was zur anderen Seite sagen, dass die Speicherung dieser Daten ganz hervorragend ist. Jens, es wird sehr interessant, ich hoffe, dass du dranbleibst. Stefan, dir einen schönen Tag noch, schönen Abend, danke für den Anruf. Und allen anderen solltet ihr am Telefon hängen und jetzt gerade nicht durchkommen unter 0331 70 97 110. Ihr könnt sowohl im Netz mitdiskutieren unter fritz.de, ihr könnt auch eine Mail schicken an chaosradio at ccc.de oder aber ihr bleibt eine Sekunde dran bis nach den Nachrichten.
Rock in Kaputt, das Open Air, Samstag 12. Mai, auf dem Festplatz Kaputt in Kaputt.
Mehr Infos fritz.de.
Rock in Kaputt, gute, neue, laute Musik, südlich von Potsdam.
Und das hört man.
Halb zwölf. Fritz.
Der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert gerät wegen des Libanon Krieges vor einem Jahr auch in den eigenen Reihen unter Druck. Außenministerin Livni legte ihm den Rücktritt nahe, ähnlich äußerte sich auch der Fraktionsvorsitzende von Olmerts Regierender Kadima Partei. Eine Untersuchungskommission hatte den Ministerpräsidenten vorgeworfen, den Krieg im Libanon voreilig begonnen zu haben, ohne andere Möglichkeiten zu prüfen. Olmert selbst lädt einen Rücktritt bislang ab. In der Türkei hat die Partei von Regierungschef Erdogan vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen beantragt. Hintergrund ist die gescheiterte Wahl des neuen Staatspräsidenten. Weil die Opposition die Wahl boykottierte, wurde sie vom Verfassungsgericht für ungültig erklärt. Außenminister Gül will am nächsten Sonntag aber erneut für das Präsidentenamt kandidieren. Er gehört der gleichen Partei an wie Regierungschef Erdogan. Beiden wird vorgeworfen, sie wollen die Bildung eines islamischen Staates vorantreiben. Bundesinnenminister Schäuble hat sich nach dem zweiten Islamengipfel optimistisch geäußert. Man sei sich einig gewesen, dass an der Trennung von Staat und Religion festgehalten werden müsse. Der Zentralrat der Muslime äußerte sich nach dem Treffen kritisch. Es könne nicht so weitergehen, dass man zielos nur debattiere, sagte Zentralratspräsident Köhler. Die Islamkonferenz will dazu beitragen, die Integration der mehr als 3 Millionen in Deutschland lebenden Muslime zu verbessern. Zum Sport. Der AC Mailand hat das Finale in der Fußball Champions League erreicht. Im zweiten Halbfinale gewann der AC Mailand gegen Manchester United mit 3 zu 0. Gegen am Finale ist der FC Liverpool. Und die deutsche Eishockey-Nationalmannschaft hat bei der WM in Russland ihren ersten Sieg gefeiert. Im dritten Spiel gewann das Team gegen Norwegen mit 5 zu 3 und sicherte sich damit auch den Klassenhalt. Abends und nachts ist es nur leicht bewölkt und trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 2 Grad. Am Tag dann wieder Sonne, Sonne, Sonne. Die Temperaturen klettern auf bis zu 22 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz A10 Spreeau Richtung Schwaneberg. Zwischen dem Dreieck Spreeau und Freien Brink haben wir Verkehrsbehinderung durch einen defekten LKW. Der rechte Fahrstreifen ist dort blockiert. Ansonsten sind die Straßen freien. Wir wünschen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Grisha, es ist jetzt vier Minuten und halb zwölf. Eigentlich müsstet ihr seit vier Minuten das Licht aushaben. Aber hey, Punk Rock, wir machen einfach weiter. Chaos Radio auf Fritz.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt oder...
Wunderbare Musik, die Musik hat Frank mitgebracht. Frank ist Mitglied vom Chaos Computer Club, dem CCC. Jetzt ist dein Mikrofon noch gar nicht offen, Frank. Ja, äh, okay, gut, dann darüber wollten wir...
Living Room Rockers.
Wohnzimmer Rocker.
Lighter Crew.
Okay, auch sehr schön. Haben wir das geklärt? Wir wollen aber heute weniger über Musik reden, sondern vielmehr über biometrische Vollerfassungs, nämlich Chaos Radio 123. Wir haben jetzt schon ganz viele Sachen gehört über Daten, die der Staat von euch speichert. Ob ihr das gut findet oder nicht gut findet. Darüber können wir noch eine Weile weiter diskutieren unter 0331 77 97 110. Wir werden noch was hören zum Thema zentrale Datenbank. Wir werden was hören zum Thema Passgesetz. Was steht da eigentlich alle drin und was soll das alles werden? Aber am Telefon ist jetzt erstmal Jens aus Berlin. Und Jens steht der ganzen Datenerfassung nicht ganz so negativ gegenüber, wenn ich das richtig begriffen habe. Guten Abend Jens.
Ja also prinzipiell bin ich der Meinung, man soll nicht so viel Angst davor haben. Man geht ja erst mal davon aus, dass man sich nicht so viel zu Schulden kommen lässt.
Unschuldsvermutungen?
Ja ich gehe auch davon aus, dass da nicht nur irgendwelche, sag ich mal, geistesgestörten Leute damit umgehen. Also eine gewisse Sicherheit der Daten sollte natürlich gewährleistet werden, vom Gesetz her und auch von der technischen Seite her. Aber ich hätte zum Beispiel nichts dagegen, wenn auf meiner Krankenkarte mein Krankenbild abgebildet wäre und ich nicht jeden Arzt wieder neu erklären müsste und ich nicht fünfmal gerönscht werde und damit die Kosten explodieren und jeder weiß sofort, welche Medikamente ich habe etc. Ich habe einen Unfall, der Rettungswagen steckt, ich trage die Karte am Mann und der Rettungswagen steckt die Karte in einen Gläserchip und der weiß sofort, ich bin Bluter und bin kein Bluter, habe Blutgruppe AB, das weiß ich. Habe das und das Problem, so und so und so weiter. Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Antibiotika und so weiter. Also diese positiven Sachen daraus, finde ich einfach, wären ja auch nicht schlecht. Auch gegen den Fingerabdruck hätte ich nichts einzuwenden, wenn der zentral erfasst wird oder wie auch immer. Also das wäre mir eigentlich relativ egal.
Also du siehst das eher aus dem Punkt Kostenersparnis und dass es in bestimmten Momenten einfach zeitsparend ist und praktischer ist, wenn man so eine Datenstelle auslesen kann.
Richtig, also auch, ich sag mal so, die Zukunft wird es früher oder später sowieso bringen. Also man meldet sich heute überall an. So wie Fantasienamen kann man ja gar nicht erfinden, wie man sich überall falsch anmelden will. Und es ist ja so, ich kauf heute ein Ticket übers Internet, melde mich an, warum kann ich das nicht auf eine bestimmte Karte speichern, brauche nicht mehr das Papierding mitzunehmen, steckt dann die Karte rein, sagt ja okay, der hat das Ticket gekauft, geht rein. Also so eine Sachen, denke ich dann einfach, wären in dieser zukünftigen Welt doch recht angenehm.
Naja, das ist wie gesagt der praktische Nutzen, aber wir reden ja heute auch darüber, welche Nachteile sowas hat. Es geht ja nicht darum, irgendwie Angst zu verbreiten oder Panik zu verbreiten, sondern einfach nur einen kritischen Blick auf das zu werfen, was da auf uns zukommt und wie wir mit Daten ausgewertet werden. Natürlich magst du recht haben mit solchen Momenten, mit dem Argument, klar Krankenwagen, irgendwie kannst du nicht sprechen, jemand muss sofort wissen, wer du bist, weil du innerhalb von zwei Minuten eine Blutkonserve brauchst. Das mag der Moment sein, in dem es notwendig wäre. Interessanter ist aber die Frage, was passiert ansonsten mit den Daten, wenn die irgendwo gespeichert sind, wenn deine Krankenkasse sagt, oh, der Jens hat hier aber irgendwie, was ist denn das, wir schicken ihm einfach mal eine Erhöhung für seine Krankengebühren, weil er könnte ja so oder so. Und dann ist der Moment, wo du sagst, da ist Freunde, da ist, da finde ich aber nicht cool.
Oder du sitzt im Vorstellungsgespräch, beim Werbungsgespräch bei einem potenziellen Arbeitgeber und der sagt, na dann zeigen sie auch mal ihre Krankenkassenkarte.
Ja, gut, ich sag ja, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, ich will nur das Positive davon haben und das Negative drücke ich jetzt gar nicht.
Also interessanterweise beleuchtest du ja die positiven Seiten, während wir heute ganz viele Leute gesagt haben, ich finde das nicht gut.
Die negativen Seiten, ich sag mal so, das eine Markt muss das andere mögen. Und jetzt ist es natürlich Aufgabe des Gesetzgebers zu sagen, wer darf was, wann, mit welchen Daten, wie und wo machen.
Und wer geht mit diesen Daten wo um? Und genau deswegen sind die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club hier, die sich seit der Äonen mit nichts anderem beschäftigen, außer mit der Speicherung und Weitervergabe von Daten.
Richtig, aber ich sag mal, ich hätte jetzt nichts dagegen, wenn zum Beispiel eben auf dem Ausweis bestimmte Daten hinterlegt sind, die mich eben eindeutig identifizieren und die eben auch noch, sag ich mal, mehr als nur meinen Namen, meine Adresse speichern, um eben zu sagen, okay, der ist es. Und ich finde es besser, wenn man gewisse Daten abfragen kann, still und heimlich. Also sag ich mal, Behörden, die das dann dürfen, die dafür autorisiert sind vom Staat, vom Gesetzgeber und damit bestimmte Prozesse, also Verbrechen etc. schnell aufgedeckt werden, als wenn man ewig und drei Jahre nach irgendein Kind sucht und nicht weiß, wer hat sie umgelegt oder wie auch immer, obwohl man gewisse Daten vor Ort gefunden hat, aber sie nicht mit dem Rest der Welt abgleichen kann.
Punkte über dies auf jeden Fall gilt zu diskutieren und das wollen wir hier heute mit euch machen, im Blumen unter 0331 70 97 110. Starbuck hat schon zweimal tief eingeatmet und wollte irgendwas sagen. Hast du Kommentare dazu?
Ich könnte jetzt irgendwie zu allen deinen Argumenten was sagen. Ich wollte dir eigentlich zustimmen, solange du was von Zentralerfassung von Fingerabdrucken erzählt hast. Die Sache mit der Krankenkarte, das hat deutlich Vorteile. Das sehe ich auch und da bin ich auch eher nicht so kritisch eingestellt. Aber das Problem ist, sobald es zentral wird, haben wir ein richtiges Problem. Weil du weißt erstens nicht, wer wirklich drauf zugreifen kann. Und da zählt auch dein Argument nicht, dass es im Gesetz steht, dass nur die und die Behörde das darf, weil Gesetze werden geändert, das sieht man gerade massiv. Das heißt, wenn die Daten erst mal da sind, gibt es auch die Begehrlichkeiten. Und dann greifen halt Leute drauf zu. Das fängt halt mit irgendwie den Verfassungsschützern an oder Geheimdienstlern. Und dann ist es die Polizei. Und dann ist es halt irgendwie dein Arbeitgeber.
Oder sind es einfach nur die Daten, die Tollcollect einsammelt von der Mautbehörde. Und dann kommt die Polizei und sagt, könnt ihr uns nicht mal schnell mal diesen Computer lassen? Wir suchen jemanden, wir wollen mal gucken, wo der lang gefahren ist. Eigentlich dürfen sie nicht, aber früher oder später werden sie darauf zugreifen.
Also bei der Krankenkassenkarte muss man natürlich noch mal unterscheiden, ob die Daten jetzt wirklich nur auf der Karte gespeichert sind. Das heißt, wieder quasi diese dezentrale Speicherung. Das heißt, du hast diese Karte in einer Hosentasche und da sind die Daten. Oder ob die denn nicht doch wieder irgendwo bei einer zentralen Datenbank, bei der Krankenkasse oder sonst wo hinterliegt sind.
Moment, also dezentrale Speicherung ist ja noch was anderes, als dass du die Daten nur auf der Karte hast. Also ist halt die Frage, ob du halt der Einzige bist, der diese Daten hat, und dass du halt auch explizit zustimmen musst, wenn du die Daten rausgeben kannst.
Moment, es ist ja quasi dezentral, weil jeder Arzt seine Daten gespeichert hat. Das ist ja auch dezentral.
Aber wenn wir doch mal bei der Krankenkarte zum Beispiel bleiben. Wenn jetzt meine Versicherung wirklich es auf mich abgesehen hat, dann wissen die da auch, was ich von Krankenbild habe. Die wissen ganz genau, wie viele Rezepte werden abgerechnet, wie viele Arztrechnungen werden abgerechnet etc. Wenn es jemand heute will, kann er mir genauso, sag ich mal, gegen den Schienbein drehen.
Das wird dann nur einfacher. Ja genau, es geht einfacher, aber das ist ja das Problem. Also heutzutage musst du halt noch jemanden ransetzen, der das irgendwie bearbeitet. Das kostet Zeit, kostet Geld. Das heißt, die haben irgendwie kein wirkliches Interesse, das zu tun. Aber wenn sie halt irgendwie nur noch ihren Computer anwerfen müssen und sagen, wie heißt du irgendwie, wir klicken mal kurz und was hast du denn jetzt und dann stufe ich halt einfach mal höher. Das heißt, es geht halt wirklich viel einfacher und das ist halt die große Gefahr, die halt Leute nicht sehen, dass durch die Technisierung, das halt einfach so billig und einfach wird, dass es halt einfach dann jeder benutzen wird.
Und nicht nur das, es gibt ja sozusagen noch die zweite Ebene, die man sehen muss, nämlich die inhärente Gefahr, dass die Daten verloren gehen. Dass also zum Beispiel dein Arbeitgeber weiß, oh, was der, dieser Mitarbeiter von uns hat im letzten Monat zweimal einen Psychologen aufgesucht und der nimmt das Arzneimittel sowieso. Also diese, viele von diesen Daten haben halt auch noch einen zweiten Nutzen für jemanden, der die klaut und deshalb sind diese Daten einfach wertvoll und andere wollen die haben. Eben zum Beispiel nicht nur den Krankenversicherer, sondern der Lebensversicherer, der dir vielleicht dann nicht mehr so gerne Lebensversicherung zu günstigen Konditionen anbieten möchte, weil er weiß, du hast die Krankheit sowieso.
Also ich habe da ein ganz gutes Beispiel, was ungefähr vor einem Monat in der Presse war. Und zwar bei der Bundeswehr oder bei der Musterung, wenn man dort halt falsche Daten zum Beispiel angegeben hat, um sich ausmustern zu lassen, gibt es halt den Dienst für Versicherte, die halt einfach dort anfragen können, was haben denn die Leute damals so angegeben. Und selbst wenn du da gelogen hast, stellen sie dir evtl. keine Versicherung aus, weil sie irgendwie sagen, du hast die und die Schäden irgendwie damals angegeben und deswegen kriegst du jetzt die Versicherung nicht. Das heißt, dass Leute auf Daten zugreifen, wo du eigentlich damals, als du sie abgegeben hast, nicht davon ausging, dass sie jemals irgendwie verwendet werden.
Und im Zweifelsfall, um dann diese Diskussion, die sich jetzt ein bisschen abstrakt weiterspint, abzuschließen, das Argument, wenn man irgendwie einen Unfall hat und man kann nicht sprechen, die Leute wollen wissen, welche Blutgruppe du hast, das kann man relativ einfach klären, indem man zu seinem Arzt geht, die Blutgruppe bestimmen lässt und sich ein Zettel ins Portemonnaie tut, da steht sowas drauf.
Ja, ich bin ja auch nicht so blauäugig, dass ich jetzt sage, ich sage jetzt zu allen Jahren armen, also ich möchte auch nochmal, das habe ich auch in der Anmoderation schon gesagt, dass man natürlich gewisse Sachen schon stark überwacht. Ich finde es zum Beispiel persönlich ein Unding, dass die Bundesdruckerei verkauft haben. Also solche Sachen, das dürfte eigentlich überhaupt nicht geben. Da hätte ein viel größerer Schrei durch die Republik gehen müssen.
Und all diese Sachen, über die reden wir ja heute, und dass wir die sozusagen in der Gänze und in der Gesamtheit uns mal angucken. Jens, auf jeden Fall dir vielen Dank, dass du das mal auch von der anderen Seite beleuchtet hast und nicht einfach nur quasi auf diesen Sack drauf haust und hoffst, dass irgendjemand schreit. 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio Teil 123 auf Fritz. Wir reden heute über biometrische Vollerfassung. Wir hatten eben gerade das Stichwort zentrale Datenbank. Bislang ist es doch so, Frank, dass diese Daten nicht zentral gespeichert sind.
Genau, wir haben diese sogenannten dezentralen Melderegister. Das heißt also alle Daten über wo wir wohnen, unseren Pass, unseren Personalausweis, unser Foto sind also tatsächlich nur bei den Einwohner-Mädeämtern, so heißen hier bei uns, gespeichert. Da sind sie zwar mittlerweile auch schon elektronisch, aber eigentlich ist es quasi wie eine große Datei. Und wenn jetzt eine Behörde von außen anfragen will, also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel das Finanzamt anfragen will, aber ich glaube Finanzamt ist noch ein bisschen ein Spezialfall, aber wenn jetzt irgendeine Behörde da anfragen will, dann muss sie da quasi erstmal einen bürokratischen Weg gehen. Es ist also nicht so, dass sie da einfach so eine Abfrage am Computer machen können, dass es geht nur für bestimmte Behörden. Aber auch das soll im Zuge dieser Verwaltungsmodernisierung aufgehoben werden. Im Moment gibt es sogenannte Clearing-Stellen. Da ist Constanze aber auch ein bisschen, weiß er ein bisschen besser Bescheid.
Clearing-Stelle klingt spannend, da können wir wirklich nachher noch was dazu hören.
Genau, das sind so quasi wie Sammelzentren oder sowas, die diese Behörden von diesen Abfragen bündeln oder auch noch mal kontrollieren, gegenchecken.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal ganz allgemein auch ein bisschen auf die rechtliche Seite kommen. Weil wir auch im Wiki, wir haben mal so eine Wiki-Mitmachseite, eine gefragt.
Moment, für die Landwirtschaft, was ist ein Wiki?
Also es ist ein interaktives Angebot an Software.
Also eine Webseite, auf der ich selber was schreiben kann.
Genau.
Okay, und die finde ich wo?
Die ist auch verlinkt, wenn man chaosradio.ccc.de, dann ist da ein Link auf die Mitmachseite.
Genau, chaosradio.ccc.de ist unsere Homepage, wie man so schön sagt. Und da sind auch noch mal alle Sachen. Wir haben auch einen Ticker, wo normalerweise die Sendung angekündigt wird und wo auch nochmal die E-Mail-Adresse steht.
Später ist da auch der Podcast.
Warum klingt das Wort Homepage aus deinem Wort so altmodisch, so schön altmodisch? Das klingt so, als auch meine Oma sagt, supikurn.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach, nicht so nach Web 2.0 irgendwie.
Okay, aber zurück zum Thema, wir waren bei der rechtlichen Seite. Konstanze.
Also wir müssen vielleicht, wir gehen nochmal kurz zurück zum 11. September, der ja für uns in der Gesetzgebung hier eine Menge geändert hat, weil ja schon zwei Monate nach dem 11. September der sogenannte Otto-Katalog, also eine Gesetzesänderung, in die Wege geleitet wurde, wo sehr viele… Ja, benannt nach Otto Schili, dem damaligen Innenminister, wo eben eine ganze Menge Gesetzesänderungen geplant wurden. Also unter anderem Bundesverfassungs-Gericht, Bundesverfassungs-Schutzgesetz und MAD, also der Militärische Abendschirmdienst und BND, Bundesnachrichtendienst und die Bundespolizei und BKA-Gesetz. Also all diese Gesetze. Und unter anderem war eben hier auch die Novelle des Passgesetzes und des Personalausweisgesetzes geplant. Und da war auch schon die Forderung, dass man hier die Grundlagen gesetzlicher Art schaffen soll, um die Biometrie eben hier per Gesetz zu legitimieren, also die Rechtsgrundlagen zu schaffen.
Dass man biometrische Daten in den Dokumenten speichern kann.
Wobei man ganz kurz noch bösartig sein kann, dass diese Gesetze da nicht geplant worden sind, sondern dass die im Prinzip schon alle fast fertig in der Schublade waren.
Sondern da nur quasi übertisch geschoben wurden.
Genau, aus dem Anlass rausgezogen wurden.
Das Datum, als dieser Gesetzentwurf rauskam, war der 8. November. Und man kann schon davon ausgehen, dass diese Planungen bereits komplett waren, weil in so kurzer Zeit haut man nicht so einen relativ umfassenden Gesetzentwurf raus. Davon kann man schon ausgehen. Also geplant war auf jeden Fall erstmal, dass es um einen sogenannten 1 zu 1 Vergleich geht. Also dass man die Identität des Passinhabers mit der Person, die ihn gerade bei sich trägt, verifizieren kann.
Das heißt, ob ich nachgucken kann, ob der Pass, den du hast, auch deiner ist?
Genau, da umgingen zunächst. Obwohl ja klar ist, seitens der Anschläge vom 11. September, ist klar, dass die Terroristen natürlich gültige Pässe hatten, weil sie wollten sich ja gerade unaufwendig benehmen. Aber im Zuge der Prüfung, ob hier Verfassungsrecht gebrochen würde, wurde schon von allen Juristen gesagt, nein, das ist akzeptabel, diesen 1 zu 1 Vergleich, um zu sehen, ob der Pass zu demjenigen, der ihnen hat gehört, der ist akzeptabel. Allerdings der 1 zu N Vergleich, also die Identifizierung einer Person, die wurde schon damals von den Juristen als nicht verfassungswidrig dargestellt.
Moment, der Unterschied zwischen 1 zu 1 und 1 zu N war mir jetzt nicht klar.
1 zu 1 heißt einfach nur, wir haben zum Beispiel das Dokument, der Pass, und daneben stehe ich, und dann checkt man eben, ob ich der Besitzer dieses Passes bin. Und es geht eben nicht darum, dass man gegen eine Datenbank checkt, wegen meiner mit einem Fingerabdruck und eben durch die Datenbank durchlaufen lässt und guckt, zu wem gehört dieser Fingerabdruck.
Achso, dass du quasi gar nicht mehr anwesend sein musst bei dem Vergleich.
Und also wir haben da, kann man auch mal nachlesen, wenn man will, Paragraf 1 Absatz 2 Satz 2 im Personalausweisgesetz. Da steht dann im Prinzip schon, dass eine bundesweite Datei nicht eingerichtet wird. Denn das wäre ja klar verfassungswidrig. Es ging also immer nur um die dezentrale Speicherung. Klar, man muss sich mal dazu vielleicht überlegen, welche Staaten weltweit solche zentralen Datenbanken haben. Das ist sowas wie Malaysia, Brunei, Oman, also schon durchaus Diktaturen, die sich sowas leisten. Und wir sind hier schließlich keine Bananenrepublik, sondern wir haben eine Verfassung. Und an die hält sich normalerweise der Gesetzgeber. Insofern war klar, dass im Passgesetz steht, keine zentrale Datei. Okay, also man kann diese Prüfung auch immer nachlesen. Die Juristen streiten sich darum, wenn so eine neue Gesetze erlassen wurden. Wir müssen vielleicht in diesem Zusammenhang auch nochmal klar machen, es wurde vorhin nicht erwähnt, dass sich auch die DNA einreiht in die Merkmale, die biometrische Art sind.
Also Gentest.
Ja, genau. Und da hat ja auch das Verfassungsgericht jetzt schon entschieden, dass die Gen-Datenbanken, die es momentan gibt, also die Gen-Datenbanken von Vorbestraften, dass die sehr restriktiv gehandhabt werden müssen. Wir müssen immer sehen, wohin in Zukunft der Weg gehen kann. Wir müssen natürlich verhindern, dass aus dem Fingerabdruck in drei Jahren eben die DNA wird. Klar. Und man muss vielleicht auch hier diese schleichende Entwicklung sehen. Dass man einfach ganz schleichend so eine Einführung einer PKZ durch die Hintertür hat. Nämlich über diese sehr eindeutigen biometrischen Merkmale. Und hier kann man in der ganzen juristischen Literatur nachlesen, dass im Prinzip die Mehrheit aller deutschen Juristen, die sich mit Verfassungsgericht befassen, sagen, nein, das ist klar verfassungswidrig.
Also Personenkennziffer, das was wir vorhin schon mal erklärt haben, das was es in Skandinavien gibt, was es in Amerika mit der Sozialversicherungsnummer gibt, dass jeder eine fest zuordnbare Nummer hat und ich brauch dann nicht mehr deinen Namen oder deinen Fingerabdruck oder deine Personalausweisnummer, sondern ich brauche nur diesen Zahlenkombination, hacke die in irgendein Rechner und sofort kommt eine komplette Akte über Konstanze vom Chaos Computer Club und sowas möchte man dann eigentlich nicht.
Genau, zumal man ja den Fingerabdruck, der ja dann diese Nummer ist, also der Bild von dem Fingerabdruck in Form einer Nummer, man wird den ja nicht mehr los. Der ist ja einfach an einem dran klebend.
Und wenn man einmal in so einer Datenbank drin ist, irgendwie reingerutscht ist, in die böse-böse-Liste, aus welchem Grund auch immer, wenn man im Auto gepopelt hat und dabei fotografiert wurde oder so, dann ist es umso schwieriger, das wieder loszuwerden und wieder sozusagen auf die Liebe-Seite zu rutschen.
Klar, und wenn man halt Pechert und gerade einen Flug nach Afghanistan gebucht hat, dann landet man halt, wenn man große Pechert in Guantanamo.
Und vielleicht bei Amazon noch die Che Guevara Biografie bestellt hat.
Ganz schlicht, sollte man nicht hören.
Übers Internetkarten fürs Ernst-Busch-Konzert. Also ihr seht, das ist ein weites Feld und wenn man drüber nachdenkt, macht es so und genau deswegen gibt es das Chaosradio.
Genau. Na ja, und klar ist auch, wenn wir jetzt nochmal zu den Ausweisdaten zurückkommen, dass natürlich heute schon und auch nach dem neuen Passgesetz die Behörden an diese Daten ran dürfen, allerdings nicht an die biometrischen. Hier ist einfach klar ein Unterschied gemacht worden und gerade das sollte jetzt eben ausgehebelt werden. Das ist gerade auch die aktuelle Debatte, wo sich die CDU und die SPD streiten.
Die SPD sagt nein und die CDU sagt, oh, gute Idee.
Also für die Gesichtsdaten haben sie das ja gerade zumindestens auf den Weg gebracht, die Entscheidung, also die Entscheidung halt geändert.
Genau. Also momentan steht halt noch drin, dass eben die biometrischen Daten nicht dazugehören, wenn man eben Auskunft verlangen will, aber das soll gerade gekippt werden. Da hoffen wir natürlich, dass die SPD da obsiegt und sich durchsetzen kann.
Im Speziellen heißt das halt für Gesichtsbilder. Also die Gesichtsbilder werden halt jetzt bei den Meldestellen, also die Bilder werden halt bei den Meldestellen gelagert. Und wenn halt eine Behörde darauf zugreifen will, dann muss sie halt einen Antrag stellen bei dem Meldamt. Was sie halt jetzt beschlossen haben, was sie dann irgendwann umsetzen werden, ist, dass in Ausnahmefällen darf die zuständige Behörde das jetzt irgendwie auch online machen, ohne dass das Meldamt dazu beitragen muss. Und die Ausnahmefälle sind außerhalb der Öffnungszeiten. Genau. Das mag jetzt erstmal lustig klingen, aber im Endeffekt heißt es halt nichts anderes als sie werden halt warten, bis 18 Uhr vorbei ist und dann halt ihre Anfragen stellen und keiner kriegt sie dann mit.
Und im Zweifelsfall ist es dann aber, dass es ein anderes Thema ist, wie sicher ist so eine Datenleitung und wie komme ich einfach rein? Und wenn ich nicht die Behörde bin, wer ist der andere?
Also hier ist auch noch ganz klar, dass in dem Passgesetz bereits drinsteht. Und auch alle Juristen dann immer unterstreichen, dass die Datensicherheit sowieso gegeben sein muss. Das ist also auch gesetzlich vorgegeben, dass die gewährleistet sein muss. Klar. Vielleicht nochmal, um das auch nochmal klar zu machen, wie es denn ist mit Verhandlung oder an einer Grenze. Also momentan ist es auch so geregelt, dass die Daten von diesem dezentralen Mädeämter, also vom Personalausweis, die dürfen verwendet werden für zum Beispiel Verhandlungszwecke auf Antrag. Aber hier ist auch explizit darauf hingewiesen, dass die biometrischen Daten eben nicht verwendet werden dürfen. Und zwar hat es auch verfassungsrechtliche Gründer, denn die dürfen eben nur zweckbestimmt verwendet. Der Zweck dieser Erhebung der biometrischen Daten ist eben nicht, die Verhandlung und Grenzkontrollen zu verwenden. Insofern müssen sie auch hier das Gesetz ändern, damit sie ihre Pläne mit dieser zentralen Datei durchsetzen können.
Aber das hat ja bei den Mautdaten auch nicht so lange gehalten. Wollte ich gerade sagen, ja. Sie sind ja auch im Gesetz drin, sie sind halt wirklich nur zu dem Zweck dieser Mautabrechnung. Natürlich kamen dann auch prompt gleich danach wieder die Diskussionen auf, naja, wenn wir die Daten schon haben, dann können wir sie auch für die Fahndung verwenden. Ist ja jetzt blöd, diese schönen Daten wegzuwerfen.
Also jetzt gleich den Zusammenhang wieder mit automatischem Abgleich in den Meldeämtern. Das heißt irgendwie, was man jetzt halt tun kann, ist, man nimmt sich die Daten, die von der Mautbrücke fallen, popelt sich da die Gesichter raus.
Was fallen da für Daten runter?
Ja, Bilder. Also es wird auf jeden Fall nicht nur von LKWs, wie halt irgendwie allgemein angenommen wird, also die Daten aufgenommen, sondern von jedem Auto, das ist unten durchfällt erstmal. Und es wird halt sowohl ein Foto des Nummernschilds, als auch ein Foto des Fahrers, also halt ein Bild des gesamten Frontpartie des Autos gemacht. Und da kann man natürlich die Gesichter wunderbar rausnehmen, die Gesichter dann wunderbar irgendwie in die Datenbank werfen und abfragen, wo der denn jetzt gemeldet ist und was der da noch so auf dem Kerbholz hat.
Wobei, da muss ich ja nochmal für Tollcollect ein bisschen in die Bräche springen. Ungern, aber es ist natürlich, also das war zumindest nicht der ursprüngliche Gedanke davon. Und das ganze System sollte schon so datenschutzfreundlich aufgebaut sein, dass die Gesichter möglichst nicht zu erkennen sind. Und es ist auch so, dass die Gesichtsbilder oder die ganzen Daten eigentlich auch sofort nach der Erfassung weggeworfen werden. Das heißt, es bestehen irgendwelche Zweifel daran, ob diese Kennzeichenerkennung funktioniert hat. Aber man muss natürlich schon sehen, diese Kameras stehen da. Und sobald der Wunsch da ist, diese Daten auch noch weiter zu verwerten, kann man dieses System auf jeden Fall auch aufbohren, die Software entsprechend ändern, dass man dann möglicherweise zumindest von bestimmten Fahrzeugen auch die Bilder aufbewahrt und dann möglicherweise auch die Personen erkennen kann.
Du musst die Software nicht mehr ändern. Es gibt irgendwie die in die Backmode, die halt genau die Daten einfach so rauswirft, wie du sie haben willst.
Ja, wobei die Bilder, die da jetzt erzeugt werden von den Kameras, die sind mit Sicherheit noch nicht für eine automatische...
Das ist ein Moment, meine Damen und Herren. Warte mal, das führt jetzt wahrscheinlich in eine sehr technische Diskussion rein.
Es ist vor allen Dingen so, ein System, was der Gestalt gebaut ist, dass es erstmal alle aufnimmt und dann wegwirft, hat mit dem Grundsatz, der in Deutschland generell gilt für alle Daten, nämlich der Grundsatz der Datensparsamkeit, genau nichts zu tun. Sie haben es de facto so gebaut, dass ihr erstmal alle aufnehmt.
Also man hätte wirklich bessere Chancen gehabt, ein Mautsystem zu bauen, halt billiger, datensparsamer. Aber die Regierung damals hat explizit das schon so ausgelegt, dass sie genau die Sachen machen können, die sie jetzt machen wollen.
Es gibt ein Gesetz, das Datensparsamkeit gemacht werden soll?
Ja, wir haben behaupten, der Grundsatz der Datenschutzgesetzgebung hier in Deutschland, aber auch in der EU-Richtlinie, die den Datenschutz europaweit festlegt, ist natürlich dieser Grundsatz immer gegeben. Man braucht zwingend immer eine Zweckbindung. Man muss sagen, wofür will man diese Daten haben? Man muss sie immer datensparsamer heben. Also nur das, was tatsächlich notwendig ist. Das sind ganz allgemeine Grundsätze, die in Deutschland und in Europa gelten. Und da hat Toll Collect von vornherein schon mal ein falsches System gebaut, weil sie einfach erst mal alles aufnehmen und dann wegwerfen.
Stichwort Datensparsamkeit, da möchte ich ganz kurz die Frage in den Raum stellen, um dann auch die Uhr zu gucken. Datensparsamkeit ist gegeben. Wie ist das eigentlich mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, wenn man von 80 Millionen Bürgern die Handydaten sichert? Wir sind im Chaosradio 123 auf Fritz. Wir reden im Allgemeinen über die biometrische Vollerfassung. Zu Gast sind Starbucks, Frank und Constanze vom Chaos Computer Club. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, es ist gerade 0 Uhr. Ihr seid eingeladen mitzudiskutieren und mit anzurufen. Wir haben uns jetzt ein bisschen bei der Firma Toll Collect und Datenschutz verzettelt. Wir wollen mal wieder in die Telefonleiste greifen. Am Telefon ist zum Beispiel, ah Mensch, mit so einem schönen Namen, aus Bad Wilsnack, guten Abend, Jakob. Kannst du mal bitte deine Eltern grüßen und sagen, dass sie einen hervorragenden Namen rausgesucht haben? Ok, kennst du die Frage mit C oder mit K?
Ja, ein bisschen verwirrt bin ich, weil so viele sozusagen Daten hin und her schwirren, irgendwie Datensparsamkeit und irgendwie Handynummer. Ich hatte folgendes Problem. Die Polizei wollte mich telefonisch erreichen.
Weswegen?
Weil in meinem hier in Bad Wildsnack, in meinem Häuschen, irgendwie was passiert ist und das wäre ganz gut gewesen, wenn mich die Polizei hätte auch erreichen können in Berlin jetzt. Und anscheinend konnten sie mich telefonisch nicht erreichen, war zumindest die Auskunft, weil meine Telefonnummer schlichtweg nicht im Telefonbuch steht. Also da habe ich sozusagen auch für Datensparsamkeit gesorgt.
Katastrophal.
Katastrophal. Nun haben sie mir anscheinend einen Polizeiwagen vorbei geschickt. Ich war nicht zu Hause. Die Datensparsamkeit haben sie anscheinend auch wörtlich genommen und haben irgendwie nicht beim Nachbarn geklingelt, was jeder Werbesritze irgendwie macht, um mir wenigstens irgendwie ein Zettelchen in den Briefkassen zu stecken. Äh, melde dich doch, weil wir würden dich gerne erreichen wollen oder wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall kam dieser Kontakt irgendwie so irgendwie nicht zustande. Und äh, was mich ein bisschen geärgert und auch verwundert habe. Also warum weiß die Polizei in dem Falle mal irgendwie nicht meine Telefonnummer. Auf der anderen Seite irgendwie wegen, sag ich mal, Daten, die man gerne irgendwie freiwillig rausgibt. Äh, ein Tipp bei Google und schon hätten sie eigentlich meine Telefonnummer gehabt, ne. Also das wundert mich dann manchmal schon.
Auf der anderen Seite bin ich in der Zeit auch ein bisschen erschrocken.
Vielleicht hatten sie keinen internetfähigen Computer auf dem Amt.
Ja, entweder der Computer ging nicht oder sie hatten im Auto keinen Rechner. So was gibt es ja. Oder es gibt ja auch Büros, wo es kein Internet gibt, kein externer, sondern du hast nur ein Intranet. So was gibt es auch.
Wie ist es denn ausgegangen?
Ja, irgendwie, das ging irgendwie nachher. Sie haben mich hier irgendwie mal wieder erreicht, also dann mehr oder weniger zufällig und irgendwie zwei Wochen danach. Das war dann okay, aber das andere war, worüber ich mir so Gedanken gemacht hab, wie viel Daten man selber sozusagen auch rausgibt, ne.
Und freiwillig, meinste?
Ja, freiwillig übers Internet. Also ich kann ja irgendwie einen Namen eingeben, da weiß ich, was, der wann, wo irgendwie mal Anzeigen aufgegeben, Artikel geschrieben hat oder Piep-Hapor ist. Das kann man so im Nachhinein, wie sehr man auch zurückhaltend ist, an offizieller Stelle irgendwie Daten rauszugeben. In meinem Fall wär's irgendwie schön gewesen, wenn sie sich ein bisschen mehr Mühe gemacht hätte. Und andererseits, wie oft man Daten rausgibt, einfach so, ohne sich da einen Kopf zu machen, was nicht der böse Staat irgendwie mit treiben könnte, sondern sozusagen schlichtweg jeder weltweit.
Ja, lässt du dir einfach irgendwie bei einer großen Tankstelle so eine Rabattkarte geben und die Tankstelle arbeitet wiederum mit irgendeiner anderen Firma zusammen, mit dem Autohaus und so weiter und so fort. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema, Rabattkarten und Payback-Systeme.
Das ist ein anderes Thema.
Da gibt's übrigens auch höchst interessante Sendungen vom Chaos Computer Club dazu. Die kann man sich unter ccc.de als Podcast ziehen und nochmal anhören. Und ich glaube, es wird demnächst auch nochmal wieder Sendungen zu diesem Thema geben, Konstanz.
Oder ein Foto bei MySpace eingeben. Das sind dann oft die biometrischen Daten.
Das ist ja ganz klar, das ist eine Sache, das machen die Leute freiwillig. Ob es denn jetzt so bewusst ist, was sie tun, ist eine andere Sache. Aber du hast natürlich selbst in der Hand und bist für die Sachen selbst verantwortlich. Und was anderes ist aber, wenn du vom Staat her verpflichtet wirst, also bei irgendwie Androhungen von, keine Ahnung, 1000 Euro Bußgeld, Spankzwingungshaft, um dir wirklich deine Fingerabdrücke, deine biometrischen Daten abzugeben.
Das muss man hier vielleicht nochmal so explizit sagen, dass man ab November dieses Jahres verpflichtet ist, mehr oder weniger seine Fingerabdrücke dem Staat abzugeben. Man wird einfach nicht im Grunde ein.
Wenn du die EU verlassen willst, ja.
Dann darfst du nur noch in Deutschland wohnen und darfst spätestens nach Ablauf deines alten Personalausweises diverse Sachen nicht mehr tun.
Also es gibt kein Nein. Du hast eine Pflicht, diesen Pass zu haben. Und dieser Pass hat eben jetzt eine neue Form von Daten, die erhoben werden. Da kannst du nicht Nein sagen. Das Einzige, was du machen kannst, ist, dich durch die Instanzen zu klagen und dich richtig zu wehren. Das ist deine einzige Möglichkeit.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz. Wir reden jetzt einmal über die Reisepässe. Da ist es also ziemlich klar, dass ab November 2007 kommen da die Fingerabdrücke rein. Und wir reden über die Personalausweisung. Bei Personalausweisen ist es so, dass die Diskussion noch nicht abgeschlossen ist. Das ist noch nicht final. Aber auch da wird es eine Modernisierung geben. Da ist geplant, dass da ein Chip drin ist. Und zumindest, wenn es nach den Wünschen von den eher Hardlinern gibt oder von Leuten, die jetzt auch, wenn man jetzt die Polizei, nicht die Polizei, das ist ja auch eine interessante Sache, sondern die Kriminalbeamten bzw. auch einfach Innenpolitiker fragen, die sagen, naja, wir hätten natürlich auch gerne Fingerabdrücke drin. Und spätestens dann habe ich auch nicht mehr die Wahl, ob Personalausweis oder Reisepass, sondern dann sind einfach die Fingerabdrücke in beiden drin. Das heißt, ich habe also dann wirklich de facto eine Verpflichtung, meine Fingerabdrücke abzugeben.
Aber das ist doch super, dann gibt es keine Verbrechen mehr, keiner bricht mehr irgendwo ein, es klaut keiner. Einfach fantastisch. Dann leben wir doch im Schlaraffenland, alles ist toll.
Einfach super. Wir können dann auch schon sehen, wo die Entwicklung dann hingeht, weil in den USA sind sie ja mittlerweile schon so weit, dass sie entdeckt haben, naja, mit zwei Fingerabdrücken ist ja auch nicht so toll und deshalb führen sie da jetzt für lumpige 50 Millionen Dollar jetzt 10 Fingerabdrucksystem ein. Also man sieht schon mal, wohin es geht.
Auf jeden Fall solltest du mit deinem Nachbarn mal reden, dass er immer mal ein Auge auf dein Haus hat, wenn er wieder das Licht an ist oder die Katze weggerannt ist, dass nicht die Polizei vorbeikommt.
Ja, hier funktioniert es noch.
Oder schreib doch deine Telefonnummer in eine Türklingel. Also so Handy-Nummer.
Genau, oder fahr einfach nicht mehr weg.
Aber ich frag mich jetzt wirklich, ist das jetzt Schlamperei gewesen oder sind sie nicht rangekommen?
Na, sie hatten einfach kein Interesse.
Hatten kein Interesse, ne?
Ja klar, im Zweifelsfall ist es eben Aufwand zu dir zu fahren und naja, weißt du.
Aber wir müssen jetzt nochmal sagen, man kann nichts gegen Fingerabdrückaufnahme tun, ist ja nicht ganz richtig. Also man kann sehr wohl sich die Fingerabdrücke so verunstalten, dass sie halt beim Abnehmen keine Erfolge mehr haben und halt genau in der Datenbank dann Abdrücke haben.
Ja, aber Starbuck in der Flex fassen tut ziemlich weh.
Ne, man kann Seuchen nehmen, da tut weniger weh.
Also, ne, man kann halt, also das Abschleifen tut tatsächlich weh, habe ich auch schon probiert. Aber was man halt tun kann...
Don't try this at home.
Genau, ne, was man tun kann ist zum Beispiel einfach Kleber zu benutzen. Also einfach, bevor man zum Passamt geht, einfach mal seine Finger kurz in Kleber halten und sagen wie, ja, ich bin Handwerker, ich habe das irgendwie jedes Mal und tut mir leid. Dann wird man mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit einfach drum kommen, dass man seine Fingerdruck in der Datenbank abgibt. Und wenn das halt viele Leute machen...
Naja, wir haben eigentlich jetzt bei der letzten CeBIT erfahren, dass wenn man alle acht Finger, die sie durchprobieren, dann nehme ich der Zeigefinger auf beiden Händen, nicht gut genug ist, dann nehmen sie einfach den Mittelfinger und so weiter, bis auf den Kleinen, den nehmen sie nicht. Wenn die also alle acht schlecht sind, dann nehmen sie einfach ein ganz schlechtes Bild. Das heißt, wenn dieser sogenannte Match Score, also einfach ein Wert, den sie sich erdacht haben, ab dem das Bild ein gutes Bild ist von diesem Finger...
Du kannst so ein Bild rastern, gibst verschiedene Punkte, und je weniger Punkte übereinstimmen, ja irgendwie so...
Na jedenfalls, wenn dieser Match Score von allen acht unterschritten wird, dann nehmen sie einfach das Beste von diesen acht. Das heißt, dann wird man ein Bild voller Crap in dieser Datenbank haben, wenn man sich alle von diesen acht Fingern z.B. mit Kleber beschmiert. Aber ich möchte ja noch mal auf die Säure hinweisen. Säure ist auch toll.
Nein, aber auch don't try this at home. Vielleicht setzt sich irgendwann das Arschfoto durch. Das wäre auch ganz schön. Du setzt dich einfach drauf.
Das ist das Problem zum Thema Crap auf den Fingern, das ist halt...
Du nass aber die Arschrosette, also die...
Da, Grenze, Jugendradio. Ich hab's gesagt, Chef tut mir leid.
Das ist das Problem mit dem Crap auf den Fingern, dass man keine Fingerabdrücke erkennt, das ist nicht so unproblematisch. Und zwar, wenn an Tatort Fingerabdrücke gefunden werden, die keine Merkmale beinhalten, dann wird man mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit aus der Datenbank als potenzieller Täter rausfallen. Also es ist nicht so, dass die weggeworfen werden, sondern die kommen dann ins Raster mit rein. Und wenn sie die Abfrage machen, dann fällst du als Person, als Unschuldiger, da irgendwie raus, obwohl du im Zweifelsfall gar keine Fingerabdrücke hast. Also in der Bevölkerung gibt es ungefähr zwei bis vier Prozent der Bevölkerung, die halt keine ausreichend ausgeprägten Fingerabdrücke haben. Das ist halt statistisch erwiesen, haben irgendwie viele Untersuchungen gezeigt. Und diese Leute werden dann einfach mal massive Probleme haben. Also nicht nur beim Grenzübertritt, sondern halt genau, wenn die Daten zur Rasterung, zur Fahnung benutzt werden, dann passiert denen halt irgendwie Sachen, die sie halt gar nicht beeinflussen können.
Das ist auch immer wieder ein Argument, was diese Juristen bringen, nämlich dass biometrische Verfahren diskriminierend sind. In Deutschland betrifft es vor allen Dingen die Senioren, weil man mit zunehmendem Alter, insbesondere bei den Fingerabdrücken, mit so Abrieb zu rechnen hat. Und die Bilder werden also mit dem zunehmenden Alter immer schlechter. Und diese Ungleichbehandlung wird von den Juristen immer angeprangert in Bezug auf die rechtliche Situation.
Das heißt also im Moment ist es irgendwie, oder was eigentlich von der Regierung als Ausnahme angesehen wird, ist zwar natürlich, wenn ich die Gesamtzahl der Bevölkerung angucke, ist es eine Ausnahme. Aber für die betroffenen Personen, die sind dann natürlich keine Ausnahme mehr, sondern jedes Mal die Angepissten an der Grenze, die dann zur extra Kontrolle rausgebeten werden und sich unangenehme Fragen gefallen lassen müssen, nur weil ihre Fingerabdrücke eben nicht mit dieser Technik klarkommen müssen. Also die Technik kommt nicht mit den Fingerabdrücken.
Also man muss irgendwie so mal sehen, dass es, also schlechte Fingerabdrücke auch, wenn man die mit einbezieht, sind wir schon ungefähr bei 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Das heißt, es ist irgendwie nicht mehr eine Lapidare, sondern es sind halt 8 Millionen Leute. Das heißt, irgendwie Riesenprobleme an den Grenzen. Also eigentlich können sie das System sofort einstellen.
Aber hey, vielleicht schafft es auch Arbeitsplätze. Gut, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Warte mal ganz kurz. Jakob, die Geschichte ist jetzt damit von dir klar. Und ich hoffe, wir haben da jetzt ein bisschen Klarheit auch geschaffen. Ehe wir uns jetzt hier in den Details mit den Fingerabdrücken rumfusseln und sich Leute irgendwann auf der Straße komische Fragen gefallen lassen müssen, wie sagen sie mal, laufen sie immer im Sommer mit Boxhandschuhen rum? Mit den Fingerabdrücken. Klingen wir mal rüber nach Donauwirt zu Martin. Guten Abend Martin.
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Ich habe heute schon Zeitung angerufen.
Stimmt, wir haben schon mal telefoniert.
Wir haben deine Stimme ohnehin aufgezeichnet und wiedererkannt durch unsere Stimmerkennung.
Der Rucksack.
Nee, der Computer hat deine Nummer gespielt. Nee Quatsch, okay.
Ja, was ich noch sagen wollte, zu den RFIDs, die haben ja nicht nur vor, die RFID in den Passen einzusetzen, sondern die RF-Technologie allgemein soll ja auch in Produkten dann bei der Kasse zum Beispiel verwendet werden. Und wenn man dann seinen RFID-Personalbeweis trägt, inklusive der Produkte, die man gerade gekauft hat, die auch mit RFID bestückt sind und dann durch so einen Scanner läuft.
Und die Kreditkarte mit RFID?
Das WM-Ticket.
Und dann kann man da schöne, riesengroße Tabellen anlegen, was der Herr denn dann wo mit wieviel Geld gekauft hat.
Hast du was zu verbergen oder wie?
Wie bitte?
Hast du was zu verbergen?
Nein, das nicht, aber wird immer angepriesen, von euch ja heute auch schon mehrmals, dass man ja nicht alles preisgeben muss. Und wenn da mal die Extremvariante, ich glaube das ist auch nicht so besonders toll für eine Frau, wenn man dann nachvollziehen kann, dass er da und dort Binden gekauft hat oder irgendwelche Intimen. Oder sowas, genau, das ist ja sowieso ein sehr, sehr großes Tabuthema. Oder Medikamente zum Beispiel.
Ja, die Frage ist viel interessanter, Martin, wenn du letztens irgendwie in Hamburg warst und plötzlich Nachts um halb eins auf der Reeperbahn dringt, am Geldautomaten 200 Euro brauchst. So teuer sind die Taxis nach Hause nicht.
Oder zum Beispiel, was ja auch ziemlich die Diskussion momentan ist, bezüglich Sprengstoffe. Das sind ja so, wie diese ganzen Jugend mit diesen Sprengstoffen umgehen.
Was Jugend, Sprengstoffe? Wo bist denn du gerade?
Ja, das ist ja zum Beispiel so ein Punkt. Man kann ja sich, ist ja eigentlich altbekannt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das...
Hey Martin, das kann dir überhaupt nicht folgen.
Moment, komm gleich. Haushaltsprodukte zum Beispiel, man kann aus Hausprodukten massiv Sprengstoff herstellen.
Du hast eine Apotheke und hast unten so ein Pfad gekauft.
Nein, aber wenn jetzt jemand zum Einkaufen geht, mit seinem RFID-Pass, mit seinen Produkten, aus denen man potentiell in Anführungsstrichen Sprengstoff herstellen kann, die aber eigentlich zu den Haushaltsbusbochen putzen oder so was, dann laufen da gleich die Polizei mit denen ein.
Naja, ich wüsste nicht genau, wie du bei dir zu Hause den Kalk in der Badewanne mit Nitrolyzerin sauber machen willst.
Nein, es gibt so Dünger zum Beispiel.
Erroristische Sprengstoffe sind sehr, sehr leicht zu besorgen und sind meist aus Haushaltsstoffen hergestellt.
Gut, aber da du ja ein netter Porsche bist, wirst du ja niemals Sprengstoff bauen. Ich möchte jetzt hier bitte wirklich nicht, ganz ernsthaft, nicht auf dieser Antenne in irgendwelcher Form Sprengstoffbauanleitung haben. Dann haben wir alle ein großes Problem. Darum geht es überhaupt gar nicht. Aber die Thematik, die du angesprochen hast, RFID-Chip, also sozusagen ein Chip, der funkt, der einem Empfänger irgendwie sagt, wo das Produkt her ist, wann das wo gekauft wurde. Was das für ein Produkt ist, und dass man dann darüber nachvollziehen kann, woher kommt das her, wer hat das gekauft, Martin, der hat vorhin auch so und so viel Geld geholt, was hat er mit dem Rest von dem Geld gemacht, und was ist das überhaupt für einer. Der hat doch damals im Radio angerufen, über Sprengstoffe geredet. Lass uns doch mal gucken, wie das auf seinem Rechner aussieht. Und damit ist nur mal ein Bundesdrujaner.
Ja, das hält so irgendwie die Szene rein.
Genau, und überhaupt sollen die Geldscheine ja auch RFID-Chips bekommen und damit auch eindeutig nachvollziehbar sein.
Hanya, da sind viele Leute da rein in dieses Muster. Diese Stoffe sind so leicht zu besorgen und...
Martin, du hast da von mir gerade ein Regel gekriegt.
Schade.
Vergiss es. Martin, dir einen schönen Abend.
Jo, wünsche ich euch auch.
Danke, tschüss. Und hier keine komischen... nicht mit irgendwie Dünger in die Badewanne sauber machen.
Die Bombandatomittel im Internet, wissen wir ja.
Genau.
Ist ja auch gefährlich und ein Trainingslager für Terroristen.
Jetzt ist gut. Nahm du Ralf nach Chemnitz, grüße dich.
Ja, hallo. Ich hab nur noch eine Frage. Ich hab eine Frage. Dieser technischen Realisierung eigentlich, obwohl jetzt ja mehr diese richtigen Seiten im Mittelpunkt stehen, aber wie wird denn bei diesem E-Pass oder mit dem elektronischen Pass werden dann die Daten auf den Chip aufgebracht? Also wenn das jetzt dieses Passamt die Daten ausnimmt und auf elektronischem Wege an die Bundesgruppe reissendet, die die Pässe herstellt, dann sind die Daten auch sowieso schon zentral. Also wer kontrolliert das dort und hat man als Bürger auch die Möglichkeit, selber zu überprüfen, was dort überhaupt gespeichert wird.
Du meinst, ob man bei den Meldebehörden nachfragen kann, welche Daten von mir bei ihnen vorliegen?
Na ja, kann ich selber überprüfen, was auf diesem Chip über mich dort gespeichert ist.
Dass du den selber irgendwo reinstecken kannst, oder wie?
Und wo werden die Daten überhaupt auf diesen Chip gespeichert? Also aufgebracht. Also wenn die schon auf dem... an die Bundesdruckerei geschickt wurden, dann sind die doch dort eh schon zentral gespeichert.
Starbucks nickt Wissen. Ich glaube, der kann dir eine Antwort geben.
Also, die werden gespeichert... Also die werden halt zur Herstellung gespeichert bei der Bundesdruckerei. Müssen danach laut Passgesetz gelöscht werden. Das heißt, offiziell sind sie ja nicht mehr vorhanden. Wie das halt mit digitalen Daten so ist. Wenn sie einmal irgendwo sind und gelöscht werden, kann man sie auch nur zum Löschen markieren. Und sie sind trotzdem weiterhin da. Also das ist halt immer fraglich. Aber offiziell müssen die gelöscht werden. Und zum Thema Auslesen sagt das Passgesetz auch, dass in den Melderemptern es Geräte geben muss, die dir anzeigen, welche Daten auf dem Chip gespeichert sind. Das heißt, wenn du dir einen neuen Pass holst mit einem RFID-Chip drin, dann darfst du verlangen, dass du zu diesem Gerät geführt wirst und da deinen Pass drauflegen. Und dann wird es dir sagen, was da für Daten drauf gespeichert sind. Was du aber nicht tun kannst, ist zum Beispiel testen, ob die Fingerabdrücke, die dort gespeichert sind, mit deinem übereinstimmen. Das heißt, die zeigen dir halt nur an, sie zeigen dir ein Bild deiner Fingerabdrücke an.
Du weißt nicht, ob das deiner ist.
Du weißt halt nicht, ob du an den Grenzen mit den Fingerabdrücken vielleicht Probleme kriegen wirst, weil halt die Qualität zu schlecht ist, sondern sie zeigen dir halt bloß an. Du wirst halt nie überprüfen können, ob das alles funktioniert, bis du halt an der Grenze bist und dann das erste Mal den großen Knaller lebst.
Also ich meine, der Armourer hat mich auch manipuliert.
Da sind wir bei der grundsätzlichen Frage, wie weit du dem Staat überhaupt noch vertraust, was halt durchaus, also muss man halt immer sagen, irgendwie zunehmend schwieriger wird.
Also es ist natürlich trotzdem für dich erstmal ein Unterschied, ob du zunächst mal sehen kannst, was auf diesem Chip gespeichert ist, weil sie dir es in der Software zeigen an einem so einem Lesegerät, oder ob du eben probieren kannst, ob du mit deinem Gesicht oder mit deinem Fingerabdruck einen Wert hast, der übereinstimmt. Es hat da nochmal einen Unterschied, ob du aber generell vertraust darauf, dass dieser Chip tatsächlich die Daten, die sie dir zeigen enthält. Ja, da kannst du wirklich nur vertrauen. Außer du verkaufst dir so ein Lesegerät für zuhause.
Kann man so eine Dinger kaufen, wahrscheinlich, oder?
Na ja, du kannst natürlich die Daten, die auf dem Ausweis, sag ich mal, also die normalen, es gibt also zwei Sicherheitsbereiche, oder zwei Sicherheitsstufen, das einen sind die, sag ich mal die Daten, die jetzt auch vorne aufgedruckt sind, die sind mit einem Lesegerät und einer speziellen Software auslesbar. Da gibt es mittlerweile auch schon eine freie Software für. Man muss ja schon ein bisschen mit der Technik auskennen und dann kann man diese Daten auslesen, die natürlich nicht so spannend. Und die besonders geschützten Daten, das sind dann die biometrischen Daten, also vor allem der Fingerabdruck ist es derzeit, wenn er denn auf dem Pass drinnen und drauf ist, den kann man nur mit einem speziellen, sag ich mal, Zugriffscode abrufen. Und diesem Zugriffscode ist nur in staatlich autorisierten Lesegeräten an der Grenze gespeichert. Das heißt also nur Lesegeräte, die jetzt von der Bundesrepublik Deutschland besonders autorisiert sind, können diese Daten dann auslesen.
Bis dann mal irgendwann eins festkommt, aber wir wollen sie ja nicht beschreien. Ralf, hast du deine Frage damit beantwortet?
Ja, stimmt, die Frage haben wir noch gar nicht beantwortet.
Also offiziell ist es so, das ist die Aussage der Bundesregierung, dass ein Reisepass auch mit kaputtem Chip weiterhin ein gültiges Dokument ist. Das heißt also, der ist ja nicht plötzlich ungültig geworden, nur weil dieser Chip kaputt ist. Aber, das sagt auch das Innenministerium, dass wenn du damit an der Grenze in Kontrolle kommst, oder wann du in Kontrolle kommst, dann musst du mit einer verschärften Kontrolle rechnen. Und was auch immer das heißt, da können wir jetzt irgendwie blühende Fantasie an irgendwelche widerlichen Filme haben, was was heißen könnte. Aber so ist halt erstmal quasi die Sprachregelung der Bundesregierung dazu.
Also es hängt halt immer davon ab, wie viele Chips nachher wirklich kaputt sind. Also wenn halt jetzt die deutsche Bevölkerung sagt, irgendwie diese Speicherung von Fingerabdrücken in den Chip, das finde ich irgendwie nicht gut, deswegen machen wir die jetzt alle mal kaputt. Was übrigens technisch gesehen nicht ein wirkliches Problem ist, die auch so kaputt zu machen, dass es nicht nachweisbar ist. Aber wenn halt irgendwie an der Grenze jeder Zweite mit dem kaputten Chip auftaucht, dann werden sie halt irgendwie diese Extrakontrollen einfach mal aus Zeitgründen auf jeden Fall wegfallen lassen.
Das heißt, wir stellen uns jetzt mal praktisch vor, du läufst mit deinem neuen Pass aus dem Meldeamt und leider, leider geht dir da schon zehn Meter davon entfernt der Chip kaputt. Dann hast du sozusagen zehn Jahre lang ein Dokument, was gültig bleibt.
Na ja, naja, naja, also das Spannende ist natürlich jetzt, jetzt kommt wieder diese aktuelle Diskussion. Diese Daten sind ja dann hinterlegt und möglicherweise in einer zentralen Kartei und online abrufbar von den Behörden. Dann hat die ganze Sache ihren Zweck auch schon wieder erfüllt auf einer anderen Art und Weise. Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist wohl wahr, ganz genau.
An dem propagierten Zweck glaubt eigentlich niemand, der sich dieses IPAS Projekt mal genauer ansieht. Also die ewige Behauptung, wir würden damit irgendeinen Terroristen fangen, der wurde sowieso durch nichts belegt. Es muss jedem klar sein, dass wir bereits vor Einführung dieser biometrischen Reisepässe ein hochsicheres Passsystem haben. Und nicht mal der Bundesinnenminister sieht es anders. Also dass wir hier einen zusätzlichen Unsicherheitsmarkt mal mit diesem RFID-Ship eingeführt haben, ist offensichtlich. Und diese Propaganda von Terroristen fangen, die hat niemand geglaubt, der sich ernsthaft mit diesem Projekt auseinandergewitzt hat.
In diesem Sinne, herzlichen Glückwunsch und einen schönen Abend reichen. Das ist der erste Teil, der in der Region von Chaos Radio ausgebildet wird. Das ist der erste Teil, der in der Region von Chaos Radio ausgebildet wird. Das ist der erste Teil, der in der Region von Chaos Radio ausgebildet wird. Wir reden mit dem Chaos Computer Club über biometrische Vollerfassung. Ihr habt es in den letzten zweieinhalb Stunden, so ihr komplett zugehört habt, schon mitbekommen, ist ein sehr weites Feld, so ihr gerade zugeschaltet habt und es interessant findet, was wir hoffen. Dann könnt ihr euch selbstverständlich unter www.ccc.de durchklicken zum Chaos Radio und da gibt es dann in den nächsten Tagen auch den Podcast dieser Sendung. Wir haben unter anderem am Anfang gesprochen über die Personenkennziffer und die Sozialversicherungsnummer, die es in Amerika auch gibt und die Schwierigkeiten darüber, dass es sowas in Skandinavien schon gibt. In Deutschland wird immer mal wieder diskutiert, ob es sowas geben sollte oder nicht. Wir haben auch erörtert, warum es sowas nicht gibt und wir haben jetzt einen Anrufer aus Österreich und zwar aus Salzburg, den Severin. Guten Abend Severin.
Hallo, na nun.
Severin, in Österreich gibt es auch so eine Sozialversicherungsnummer.
Ja, also ich bin ja wirklich stolz, dass wir da so weit vor Deutschland sind. Das hätte ich mir nie erträumen lassen. Ich hab's eigentlich in meinen schlimmsten Albträumen nicht gedacht. Aber wir haben jetzt eine und zwar schon eine längere Zeit etwas. Die gibt's mindestens schon seit den 90er Jahren. Seit damals nämlich wird jeder, der in Österreich geboren wird, in diese Sozialversicherungsnummernkartei aufgenommen. So vorsorglich, also falls man mal dann irgendwann eine Arbeit kriegt, dann hast du gleich die Sozialversicherungsnummer gleich dazu. Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte ist im Zusammenhang mit dieser Sozialversicherungsnummer. Mir ist nämlich vor einigen Jahren, am Schulanfang war das immer so, da kriegste von den Kassen dir so ein Zettel ausgeteilt, wo dann draufsteht, ja du bist so und so, wohnst in der so und so Straße, hast die und die Telefonnummer, also deine Eltern haben die und das musst du dann nach Hause tragen und musst von deinen Eltern bestätigen lassen. Und auf diesem Zettel steht unter anderem die Sozialversicherungsnummer. Jetzt denken wir mal nach, wozu braucht meine Schule meine Sozialversicherungsnummer, wenn ich da gar nicht arbeiten will? Gute Frage. Habe ich mich bis heute Abend gefragt, dann habe ich die Sendung gehört. Sozialversicherungsnummer, kennst du dich vom Moment mal, da war doch mal was. Ah ja, schau dir doch mal nach, wozu die meine Sozialversicherungsnummer gebraucht haben. Ich weiß es jetzt, da brauchen die für das Bildungsregister.
Das gibt es doch bei uns auf dem Rad.
Das Bildungsregister muss es bei euch sogar auch geben, denn es ist eine EU-Institution, also eine EU-Kartei. Da steht dann unter anderem drinnen, welche Religionszugehörigkeit du hast, wann du welche Noten hattest, ob du mal sitzen geblieben bist.
Ob du ein Zappelfilip bist.
Ja, genau, es steht dann sogar drin, Verhaltensauffälligkeit.
Wie oft du den Tonbeutel vergessen hast.
Ja, und was auch schön fand ich, ob du mal einen Prüfungstermin versäumt hast.
Konntest du das alles nachlesen? Also kannst du die Daten abrufen?
Boah, das weiß ich nicht, ob man die private... Jedenfalls die Behörden haben das. Und das Lustige ist, das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich erzählen, dieses Bildungsregister ist, wie gesagt, von der EU verordnet. Alles kein Problem, österreichische Bundesregierung kann nichts dafür. Die sind zwar an vielen schuld, aber daran ausnahmsweise mal nicht. Aber weil wir so eine tolle Bundesregierung haben und die sich gedacht haben, Mensch, also unsere Österreicher, an denen müssen wir es doch besonders leicht machen, jetzt speichern wir die Daten mal für die nächsten 60 Jahre.
Na klar, man muss sich überlegen, diese Schulkinder, die werden alle Materialisten oder Kinderpornografiehändler. Andere Berufe werden die niemals wahrnehmen.
Vor allem in 50 Jahren kann ich dann zum Amt gehen und kann sagen, hey, ich wollte bei euch noch mal fragen, was habe ich denn in der 7. Klasse für Noten gehabt? Und vielleicht wird es ja noch lustiger. Vielleicht kommen ja mal dann Arbeitnehmer an die Daten dran und können dann sagen, ui, der Herr sowieso ist aber in der 7. Klasse in Chemie durchgefallen. Den können wir dann aber nicht nehmen, weil wir haben damit Chemie was zu tun.
Das gibt Abzug bei der Rente. Okay, aber ich denke die Problematik hast du schon gut erkannt, oder? Also wir haben bei uns, bei den Schülern in Deutschland momentan noch eine Debatte. Es gab diese Vorsorge in Deutschland nach der zentralen Schülerdatei, aber momentan ist es noch nicht umgesetzt worden.
Sie haben auch einen Big Brother Award bekommen.
Ja, dafür haben sie einen Big Brother Award.
Das ist ein negativer Datenschutzpreis für besondere Verdienste um Verletzung des Datenschutzes. Eine Privatsphäre wird jedes Jahr vergeben. Und da war im letzten Jahr auch diese Schülerbildungsdatei dran.
Aber trotzdem vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Das war ja ganz interessant zu hören, wie es den Nachbarn dann so abgeht.
Ich überlege jetzt ernsthaft nach Deutschland umzuziehen.
Oh, wenn ihr sucht ihr weiter, dann sind wir auch schon...
Bei uns sind wir auch schon...
Sivirin, überlegst du dir gut, bei uns moderiert Andy Borg, der Musikantenstar?
Der ist ein österreichischer Mann.
Deswegen. Wir haben jetzt gleich die Nachrichten. Nach den Nachrichten reden wir mit David aus Lübben über die Personenkennziffer, die es ja schon bei der Bundeswehr gab. Und Frank Giesgule, wenn du willst.
Genau, ich habe noch einen ganz dringenden Veranstaltungshinweis. Am kommenden Wochenende, Samstag, Sonntag, werden nämlich in Dresden die sogenannten Datenspuren stattfinden. Das ist eine Veranstaltung vom Chaos Computer Club Dresden. Und das ist ein Symposium, eine Diskussionsveranstaltung mit Vorträgen. Das ist glaube ich in einer...
W-W-W-CCCD.
Datenspuren, CCC findet man. Ja, es ist ein Samstag, Sonntag, kostet keinen Eintritt, kann jeder kommen. Und da gibt es ein Programm, das ist auf der Webseite auch zu sehen.
Und Dresden ist nicht so weit weg.
Und ihr werdet alle gespeichert.
Und auf das Camp im Sommer wollen wir schon mal hinweisen als Fortschau. Haltet euch den Termin frei, 8. bis 12. August in der Nähe von Berlin. Bei Fino Ford findet das Chaos Communication Camp statt.
Mehr Infos www.ccc.de.
Morgen Abend spielen sie live in der Columbia Halle Berlin. Blockparty. Natürlich ist dieses Konzert schon total ausverkauft. Aber ihr wisst ja, Fritz wäre nicht Fritz, wenn Fritz nicht auch eine ganz besondere Gästeliste für Blockparty hätte. Und wer auf dieser Fritz-Gästeliste steht, der kommt trotz Ausverkauf noch ein. Einfach so. Und mit ein bisschen Glück seid ihr dabei und seht Blockparty in der Columbia Halle Berlin live und für kein Geld. Denn die beste Liste ist die Fritz Gästeliste.
Und das hört man.
So sieht's aus. Mit Grisha Sidelke.
So sieht's aus. Der israelische Ministerpräsident Olmert gerät wegen des Libanon Krieges vor einem Jahr auch in den eigenen Reihen unter Druck. Außenministerin Livni legte ihm den Rücktritt nahe. Ähnlich äußerte sich auch der Fraktionsvorsitzende von Olmerts Regierende Kadimapartei. Eine Untersuchungskommission hatte dem Ministerpräsidenten vorgeworfen, den Krieg im Libanon voreilig begonnen zu haben, ohne andere Möglichkeiten zu prüfen. Olmert selbst lehnte einen Rücktritt bislang ab. In der Türkei hat die Partei von der Regierung Chef Erdogan vorgezogene Parlamentswahlen beantragt. Hintergrund ist die gescheiterte Wahl des neuen Staatspräsidenten. Weil die Opposition die Wahl boykottierte, wurde sie vom Verfassungsgericht für ungültig erklärt. Außenminister Güll will am nächsten Sonntag aber erneut für das Präsidentenamt kandidieren. Er gehört der gleichen Partei an wie Regierungschef Erdogan. Beiden wird vorgeworfen, sie wollen die Bildung eines islamischen Staates vorantreiben. Bundesinnenminister Schäuble hat sich nach dem zweiten Islamengipfel optimistisch geäußert. Man sei sich einig gewesen, dass in der Trennung von Staat und Religion festgehalten werden müsse. Der Zentralrat der Muslime äußerte sich nach dem Treffen kritisch. Es könne nicht so weitergehen, dass man zielos nur debattiere, sagte Zentralratspräsident Köhler. Die Islamkonferenz soll dazu beitragen, die Integration der mehr als drei Millionen in Deutschland lebenden Muslime zu verbessern. Zum Sportfußball der AC Mailand hat das Finale in der Fußball Champions League erreicht. Im Zweiten Halbfinale gewann der AC Mailand gegen Manchester United mit 3 zu 0. Gegen am Finale ist der FC Liverpool und die deutsche Eishockey-Nationalmannschaft hat bei der WM in Russland ihren zweiten Sieg gefeiert. Im dritten Spiel gewann das Team gegen Norwegen mit 5 zu 3 und sicherte sich damit auch den Klassenerhalt. Abends und nachts ist es nur leicht bewölkt und trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 2 Grad. Am Tag dann wieder den ganzen Tag Sonne und die Temperaturen klettern auf 22 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz, wir haben keine aktuellen Meldungen für euch und wünschen eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100 3, 2 dann Fritz im Cottbus.
Herzlich willkommen zum Blue Moon auf Fritz Chaos Radio Teil 123 mit Frank Constanze und Starbuck vom Chaos Computer Club. Wir reden heute über biometrische Vollerfassung im Allgemeinen. Wir hatten sehr ausführliche und tiefgreifende Explosionen ins Passwesen und ins Melderecht Deutschlands, wie im Moment der Stand der Dinge ist. Wir hatten sehr viele Anrufer aus Österreich und aus Skandinavien, die erzählt haben, wie es mit der Personenkennziffer und der Sozialversicherungsnummer eben speziell in diesen Ländern aussieht. In Deutschland gibt es sie noch nicht aus guten Gründen, obwohl wieder darüber diskutiert wird. Wir haben am Telefon den David aus Lübben, der vielleicht schon eine Personenkennzahl hat. Warst du bei der Bundeswehr, David?
Ja, genau da war ich gewesen. Und genau das ist mein Anliegen.
Schönen guten Abend erstmal.
Hallo.
Ich hab das den Abend über verfolgt und jeder, der beim Bund war oder Zivildienst gemacht hat, weiß ganz genau, was mit dieser Ziffer anzufangen. Und meines Wissens nach hat jeder deutsche Staatsbürger, der zumindest beim Bund irgendwo gemeldet ist.
Nee, der gemustert wurde.
Der gemustert wurde, genau.
Nee, der zur Musterung ausgestimmt ist.
Der, der erfasst ist, ne? Jeder der?
Sicher, dass du keine hast?
Ja, ich bin nicht gemustert worden, ich bin sehr sicher.
Jaja, trotzdem, es existieren ja Unterlagen über jeden Menschen, der potentiell zur Musterung gekommen wäre, hätte können.
Weil es geht ja auch nicht jede Frau zur Musterung.
Genau, also wenn du einen Brief gekriegt hast, dass du zur Musterung irgendwie erscheinen sollst, dann bist du... Ja, das ist egal heutzutage, also bei dir jetzt nicht, aber heutzutage...
Es gibt ja auch weibliche Soldaten, die kriegen ja auch alle eine Personenkennziffer. Und die besteht ja aus dem Geburtsdatum, aus der Region, wo man lebt. Und die letzten drei Ziffern sind individuell zuweisbar.
Ja, du hast natürlich auch bei deiner Krankenversicherung, hast du zum Beispiel auch quasi eine Kundennummer. Du hast bei der Versicherung auch eine Kundennummer oder sowas. Das ist natürlich schon vergleichbar, weil die Personenkennziffer von der Bundeswehr oder von der Wehrfassung ist natürlich auch erst mal nur für die gedacht. Also ist es jetzt zum Beispiel nicht so, dass du beim Auto anmelden oder so jetzt nach deiner Personenkennziffer von der Bundeswehr gefragt wirst.
Nee, das ist richtig. Aber die Bundeswehr weiß auch genau, bei welcher Krankenversicherung man ist und was man alles schon in seinem Leben gemacht hat, was man eventuell dann auch später mal gemacht wird. Nee, was man auch später mal dann macht.
Aber wie war das so im Alltag bei der Bundeswehr mit dieser Kennziffer? Hattest du das Gefühl, dass du denn da quasi diese Nummer einfach bist oder hattest du das Gefühl, dass du du bist?
Man ist quasi diese Nummer, ohne diese Nummer auf allen Anträgen, egal wo, auf allen Formularen steht ganz oben im Kopf diese Nummer drin.
Genau, super.
Und genau darauf wird das dann irgendwann hinauslaufen. Es wird eine 10-stellige Nummer mit einer Buchstabenkombination und die wird, so wie es in Amerika ist, jeder quasi bei seiner Geburt aufgedrückt kriegen und die behält man dann bis zum Tod.
Aber es ist doch schon ein bisschen ein komisches Gefühl, dass man inzwischen zu so einer Nummer degradiert wird. Also ich weiß nicht, wer jetzt so ein bisschen, also wer jetzt immer so alt ist wie wir hier ungefähr, der kennt es schon noch von der Volkszählung damals. Naja, aber der das sozusagen wirklich mitbekommen hat, weil er sich so, weil er es noch bewusst hat, wie dieser Volkszählungsboycott und wie diese quasi, da war halt damals auch relativ neu dieser Barcode, dieser Strichcode, der heute auf jedem Lebensmittel, auf jedem Artikel drauf ist. Es war damals so dieser Inbegriff für diese maschinelle Erfassung. Sie sind eine Nummer.
Okay, aber das, das sowieso. Aber was du gerade sagst, ist, dass man zu einer Nummer degradiert wird und kein Mensch mehr ist. Das ist ja eher so eine moralische Diskussion, die man ja führen kann. Aber hauptsächlich geht es ja um die Gefahren, die darin bestehen, dass man sozusagen aus einer Nummer, die jemand hat, also aus einer Buchstaben-Zahlen-Kombination, quasi alle Daten über so einen Menschen abrufen kann, aus einem Rechner, der irgendwann irgendwo stehen wird und nicht mehr sich über verschiedene Stellen die Dinger zusammensuchen muss. Das ist ja der eigentliche Grund, über den wir heute reden.
Das ist ja quasi jetzt schon der Fall. Jeder, der beim Bund war und seine PK im Kopf hat, kann beim Kreiswehrsanstab anrufen und die können einem genau sagen, was man gemacht hat. Weil die das über, oh Gott, wie heißt der große Softwarekonzern in Deutschland? SAP, weil die das über SAP verwalten und das liegt auf irgendeinem Server. Und die können alle Daten, die der Bund, also die das Kreiswehrsatzamt mal gesammelt hat, können die abrufen.
Aber wie gesagt, nochmal der Punkt ist, du kannst halt zum Beispiel nicht zum Kraftfahrzeugamt gehen und sagen, hier ist meine Personenkennziffer von der Bundeswehr und welche Autos sind denn auf mich angemeldet? Also das ist der große Unterschied von diesen dezentralen Dateien, die wir überall haben.
Das ist wohl wahr, aber dann kommt wieder die Gefahr, dass eventuell, wenn die Vernetzung dieser Dateien stattgefunden hat oder stattfinden wird, was ja quasi unaufhaltsam auf uns zukommt, dass es dann quasi geht, dass die bei der Zulassungsstelle sagen können, wo man vielleicht mal oder in welchen Fahrzeugen man mal ausgebildet wurde.
Panzerfahren.
Panzerfahren zum Beispiel.
Haben Sie überhaupt die Berechtigung, einen Panzer zu verlassen? Sagen Sie mal Ihre Bundeswehrnummer.
Das ist vielleicht noch mal ein ganz kurzer Exkurs in Richtung Volkszählung. Es gab ja diese große, unsägliche Volkszählung damals.
Ende der 70er war das?
Anfang der 80er, Mitte der 80er. Wir hatten ein bisschen später hier. Und was ziemlich wenig Leute wissen, es wird derzeit auch wieder eine Volkszählung vorbereitet. Aber das Besondere ist, es ist eine Volkszählung, von der wir nicht viel mitbekommen werden. Weil es ist eine sogenannte registergestützte Zählung, ein registergestützter Zensus. Und die Idee dabei ist, die Daten, die jetzt ohnehin in diesen Medienregistern sind, zu nehmen und quasi zusammenzuführen, zu zählen. Wobei natürlich auch jetzt festgestellt werden muss, es gibt jetzt sozusagen ein Erprobungsgesetz, wo festgestellt werden soll, wie genau diese Daten eigentlich sind. Das heißt, es werden also Testumfragen gemacht oder Testfragebögen verteilt. Man schaut dann, wie realistisch sind diese Daten überhaupt. Und da ist jetzt das große Problem, dass diese Daten auch ziemlich ungenau sind, diese Meldedaten, weil Leute auch mal vergessen, sich abzumelden oder sowas. Es gibt Leute doppelt.
Ist doch aber genau an dieser Stelle spätestens der Punkt, wo viele einzelne große Dateien zusammengeführt werden, um die Gesamtheit dann zu erfassen.
Das Problem ist halt zum Beispiel, wie erkennst du, ob ein Frank-Großengard jetzt nicht irgendwie zweimal in der Datei irgendwo gelandet ist, in zwei unterschiedlichen, weil er mal vergessen wurde, abzumelden irgendwo. Und da ist es dann natürlich die Befürworter von so einer Personenkennziffer. Ist doch prima, wenn wirklich jede Person eindeutig identifiziert werden kann, dann gibt es keine Doubletten und ganz klar ist jetzt eine Person, diese Person ist jetzt die. Und dann braucht man im Prinzip nicht zu zählen, sondern man zählt sozusagen einfach die Personenkennziffern und dann wissen wir, welche Personen wir haben. Und das ist quasi die Idee von diesem großen Zusammenführen auch.
Ich hab eine Idee. Also wo doch jetzt diese schleichende Volkszählung mehr oder minder hinter unserem Rücken kommt, lass uns doch noch mal Massenproteste machen wie 1982.
Das ist eine Spitzenidee. Vielleicht kann man das ja bei Wer wird Millionär mal als Frage stellen, damit der Rest der Welt das auch mitkriegt. David, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf. Schönen Abend noch. Am Telefon ist, ich verstehe ja, als erste Frau heute, Sarah. Schönen guten Abend, Sarah. Du musstest jetzt ein bisschen warten. Wir mussten nochmal die Exkursion zur Personenkennziffer durchführen. Wir hatten vorhin schon mal ein Gespräch zum Thema Krankenkarte und dass es gar nicht so verkehrt ist, dass da ein paar Dinge drauf gespeichert werden, wenn man sowas braucht, weil du bist Ärztin.
Ja, ich bin Ärztin. Ich muss zugeben, ich arbeite im Moment nicht im Krankenhaus. Habe ich aber gemacht. Und ich finde halt, das Beispiel ist relativ schlecht gesehen.
Das Beispiel, was wir hatten, du hast einen Unfall, kannst nicht reden und irgendjemand muss wissen, welche Blutgruppe du hast.
Ja, also das ist wirklich extremer Blutsinn, Entschuldigung. Weil die Blutgruppe wird, also ist es so, diese AB0-Blutgruppe ist relativ grob. Und darum wird in der Blutbank sowieso noch immer ab noch andere Blutgruppen feiner typisiert, so dass das eigentlich nicht so furchtbar viel hilft.
Eigentlich.
Ich meine, was natürlich wirklich nützt, wenn man weiß, hat er Grundkrankheiten, sind irgendwelche Allergien ganz wichtig, aber das kann man ja auch, wenn man das hat, auf ein Kärtchen schreiben und mit sich umtragen. Also ich finde, dafür braucht man das nicht elektronisch erfassen. Und ich meine, dass ich halt, also ich habe mir das neulich mal durchgelesen auf der Internetseite vom Datenschutzbeauftragten, wie das eigentlich gedacht ist, irgendwie mit diesen verschiedenen abgegrenzten Bereichen und PIN-Nummern für jede einzelne und was weiß ich. Und ich fürchte halt, dass es in der Praxis nicht so kommen wird, sondern halt wirklich alles, also sagen alle Informationen auf eine Karte gespeichert, was ich halt nicht so glücklich finde, weil halt Ärzte auch dazu neigen, die Diagnosen, die sie erst mal kriegen, als solche anzunehmen.
Und nicht selber nochmal nachzuprüfen, ob das wirklich stimmt.
Richtig. Also ich mein, um jetzt mal ein Beispiel zu bringen, ich habe in einem Krankenhaus gearbeitet, jetzt nicht in Berlin, muss ich zugeben, also keinen Schreck kriegen. Und da gibt es diese schöne Art, wenn man auf Stationen arbeitet, Konzile zu machen. Das heißt, man lädt sozusagen den anderen Arzt an, von einer anderen Fachrichtung seine Meinung abzugeben, damit man halt auf Gebieten, wo man sich nicht auskennt, auch eine Meinung hat und eine Behandlung hat. Und dann, es gibt halt gynäkologische Konzile, HNO-Konzile, psychiatrische Konzile. Und ich mein, wenn uns jetzt einer ein bisschen depressiv vorgekommen ist, haben wir halt ein psychiatrisches Konzil bestellt. Und das war ganz merkwürdig, dass es kamen halt häufig der gleiche Kollege und wir müssen dann eine super Vorselektion gearbeitet, also geleistet haben, weil es kam wirklich bei jedem zum gleichen Ergebnis. Und das Ergebnis war immer eine leichte Depression und bei älteren Patienten noch eine HOPs, also eine Hürn-Organische Psychosyndrom. Es gab da auch zwei Standardmedikamente und ja, die haben sie dann gekriegt. Also ob das ihnen geholfen hat, weiß ich nicht. Bei so lange sind sie zum Glück ja auch nicht auf Station. Und ich mein, so werden manchmal Diagnosen gestellt.
Also du nimmst also im Prinzip an, dass wenn man jetzt die lange Anamnese eines Patienten und die Medikamente, die er bekommen hat und die aktuellen Krankheiten immer schon so nachverfolgen könnte, dass die aktuelle Diagnose jeweils immer ändert?
Also ich möchte halt meinen, dass es halt, wenn eine Diagnose schon bekannt ist, halt diese Diagnose vielleicht auch erstmal angenommen werden. Weil in der Praxis, man hat relativ wenig Zeit für den Patienten und dann ist die Diagnose da und dann glaubt man das erstmal. Und ob die dann stimmt, ist vielleicht eine andere Frage.
Und siehst du diese Missbrauchsgefahr auch? Ich meine, es gab ja in Berlin und anders, wo diese Probleme, dass auch Krankendaten abhandengekommen sind oder dass zum Beispiel in den Krankenhäusern WLANs waren, die offen waren. Siehst du dieses Missbrauchspotenzial auch?
Also ich sehe es eigentlich schon, weil also ich meine, wenn es Missbrauch gibt bei EC-Karten, dann verstehe ich eigentlich nicht, wie die Gesundheitskarte so viel sicherer machen wollen, dass eben dieser Datenklau nicht vorkommen kann. Also mir fehlt jetzt einfach das technische Hintergrundwissen. Das habt vielleicht ihr aber.
Leider auch nicht zur Gesundheitskarte.
Also wenn es jetzt wirklich mit PIN funktionieren soll, also PINs werden ja auch so geklaut.
Nein, die PIN ist einfach dafür geplant, damit derjenige, der die Gesundheitskarte hat, also der Besitzer dieser Karte, die Kontrolle behält. Deshalb haben sie diese PIN eingeführt.
Eigentlich schon. Also vom Prinzip ist es im Moment so, also hab ich das so verstanden, dass es diese Basisdaten geben soll, die halt auf der Gesundheitskarte gespeichert werden. Vom Prinzip hat der gleiche Schlons wie jetzt auch, also halt irgendwie nahme Anschrift, Zugehörigkeit, Versicherung, Versicherungsstatus und halt irgendwie noch einen abgegrenzten Bereich mit PIN, wo dann halt irgendwie die Gesundheitsdaten drauf gespeichert werden sollen. Es gibt jetzt wohl auch irgendwie Protesteorte, aber ich hab vergessen, welche das sind.
Ja, haben wir auch gehört, dass es jetzt getestet wird.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist Thema Gesundheitskarte nochmal was für eine Ecken-Gesundheit.
Wir hatten schon mal eine Sendung über Gesundheitskarte und da kamen deutlich negative Probleme bei der Gesundheitskarte.
Ich denke, man muss sich das halt auch überlegen, weil wenn einer der Arzt irgendwie dann mal fragt, ob das darauf gespeichert werden soll, und dann sagt man vielleicht ja, und vielleicht will man das dann gar nicht mehr später.
Was wir schon mal hatten, wenn Dateien gelöscht werden sollen, heißt es nur, dass sie ziemlich markiert sind. Die sind ja dann trotzdem noch da.
Naja, oder zum Beispiel auch Stande halt drin, dass irgendwie die Idee ist, mit einem CIRS oder im Internet, wo dann die Patienten ihre Fragen abfragen sollen. Also ich meine, im Internet, gut, dann ist wieder die Gefahr des Datenklasses, aber beim CIRS kann ich mir das ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen.
Also, sitzt du noch eine Zeit?
Sarah, ich glaube, dass das wie gesagt ein Feld ist, was wir in einer der kommenden Sendungen irgendwann noch mal extern beackern werden. Hier auf jeden Fall schon mal vielen Dank für diese Eindrücke. Und einen schönen Abend noch nach Tempelhof. Einen haben wir noch und zwar aus Augsburg. Andreas ist am Telefon, kriegt quasi so eine Art Schlusswort. Hallo Andreas.
Schöne Grüße vom C3A aus Augsburg vor allem an Starbucks. Und mir geht es noch darum...
Ach je, so intern sprech.
Vor allem, wenn die jetzt beleidigt.
Kennste ihn, kennste alle. Nee, komm, jetzt läuft die Zeit ein bisschen weg. Andreas, was gibt's?
Und zwar die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja so von Anwälten und so weiter ziemlich angeprangert worden. Was mich eigentlich mal so interessieren würde, was sich die Leute, die sich das eigentlich alles ausgedacht haben, dafür Gedanken gemacht haben, was ist eigentlich mit diesen Berufsgruppen oder was ist mit Diplomaten, das ist auch in Beziehung mit den Biometriepässen, wie man diese Leute eigentlich überhaupt noch schützen will. Weil die können ja schlecht sagen, die und die IP-Adresse dürfen nicht überwachen, weil da könnte ja ein Anwalt sein. Gab's irgendwelche Ideen, wie man das umsetzt oder?
Ich glaube, das Problem ist bei den Anwälten noch gar nicht so richtig angekommen. Ich hatte heute gerade irgendwie einen Termin mit einem und die so, ach, ups, echt? Klar, das ist ein Problem, aber man kann sowas natürlich nicht ausnehmen. Es kann hinterher natürlich ein Verwertungsverbot für so eine Daten geben, aber erst mal bei der Erhebung der Daten kann man natürlich nicht unterscheiden, ob es jetzt ein Priester hat, der jetzt möglicherweise gerade ein vertrauliches Gespräch geführt oder einen Terroranschlag geplant. Das kann ich anhand von der IP-Adresse und einer Telefonnummer erst mal so nicht erkennen.
Das ist das gleiche Problem auch bei der Wohnungsüberwachung, wo die CDU gerade jetzt wieder fordert, dass erst mal alles aufgenommen werden soll und dann ein Richter in Nachhinein überprüft, ob die Daten verwendet werden dürfen. Also was das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat, so was wie Schlafzimmer darf nicht überwacht werden, wo sie jetzt schon wieder drüber nachdenken, wie sie das alles ganz umgehen können.
Ich schlafe ja im Wohnzimmer.
Sie sagen jetzt erst mal, wir nehmen alles auf, und der Richter muss dann im Endeffekt entscheiden, was davon benutzt werden darf und was nicht.
Wir haben vor allen Dingen also für die Vorratssattenspeicherung ohnehin eine Verfassungsklage, die kommen wird. Und ich denke, dass hier auch festgestellt werden wird, dass diese Art von verdachtsunabhängiger Speicherung über die ganze Bevölkerung hinweg mit unserer Verfassung nicht vereinbar sein wird. Also ich hoffe schon, dass wir dann noch gerichtliche Klärungen kriegen.
Da wird es auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Sachen geben, viele auch Datenschutzorganisationen bereiten, wie gesagt, was du gerade erzählt hast.
Das ist schon passiert.
Ich gehöre dazu.
Es sind irgendwie 3000 Leute, die sich da zusammengefunden haben. Und da gemeinsam dagegen klagen.
Und ich weiß auch schon, was Otto Schiedl dazu sagt.
Da fehlt mir das Verständnis.
Ganz genau. Andreas, dir vielen Dank für den Anruf, weil jetzt läuft uns die Zeit wirklich weg.
Wo es um spezielle Personengruppen geht, ist natürlich das Problem, wie macht man das mit Scheinidentitäten von Verfassungsschutzorganen oder BKA-Beamten, die an der Grenze dann ausreisen oder einreisen wollen, wenn die Fingerabdrücke von denen abgenommen werden, wo halt auch jeder Staat oder jeder andere Geheimdienst dann die Fingerabdruckdaten an hat.
Man hat aber auch andere Sorgen, außer irgendwie die Geheimdienstler sicher verreisen können.
Vielleicht eine Frage, die ihr noch mal mit nach Hause nehmen könnt. Das hat uns der Simon nämlich auch per Mail geschickt. Da denke ich, okay, jetzt wissen wir, wo die Probleme sind. Was können wir jetzt eigentlich tun als Bürger? Also ich meine, wir können zwar sozusagen bei der nächsten Wahl das berücksichtigen. Wir können auch noch mal irgendwie äußern, dass wir das mit den Fingerabdrücken scheiße finden. Gibt es darüber hinaus noch irgendwas, was wir tun können? Also ich meine, diese Radiosendung, dass wir jetzt darüber sprechen, das ist ja ein ganz wichtiger Schritt. Und ich denke, das ist was, was ihr einfach auch machen könnt, ist einfach wirklich, redet mit euren Freunden, redet mit euren Bekannten darüber. Das ist einfach ein Thema, das muss präsent sein. Und das ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Thema einfach, darüber zu reden.
Wir können zum Beispiel auch mal zu eurem Bundestagsabgeordneten gehen. Jedem Wahlkreis, man kann dem schreiben. Man kann seiner Stimme zum Beispiel im Internet einfach mal Gehör verschaffen. Also schriftlich oder eben zum Beispiel per Podcast. Also einfach mal die Meinung auch sagen. Wir müssen sehen, wir haben momentan in Deutschland die EU-Ratspräsidentschaft. Und wenn man sich da vom 1. Januar die Positionspapiere des Innenministeriums ansieht, dann wird einem deutlich, wohin die Reise geht. Da ist die Rede von mehr Zusammenarbeit über die Ländergrenzen hinweg für die Ermittlungsbehörden. Da ist die Rede von zentralen Fingerabdruckdateien. Da ist schon die Rede von zentralen DNA-Dateien. Also wir sehen, wo es hingeht. Und wenn der Bürger seine Stimme nicht laut macht, dann werden die einfach mal die Ministerien die Sache durchziehen.
Also sag nicht, ihr habt es später nicht gewusst. Ihr könnt diese Sendung nochmal anhören. In den nächsten Tagen gibt es sie als Podcast unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Dort findet ihr auch ein Wiki, habe ich gelernt.
Eine Mitmachseite.
Ein Feedback, da kann man mitmachen. Da findet ihr die Themen der letzten Sendung, die Themen der kommenden Sendung. Wir hören uns dann wahrscheinlich in vier Wochen wieder zum nächsten Chaosradio, dann Teil 124. Es wird dann sicherlich um Themen gehen, die uns heute auch schon mal beschäftigt haben. Stichwort Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Stichwort Biomäschung voller Versagen, Krankenkarte und so weiter und so fort. Das sind ja alles Sachen, die in den nächsten Tagen immer noch am Tisch liegen. Aber es kommen auch neue Dinge auf euch, auf uns zu. Auf euch kommt jetzt auf jeden Fall der Nightfly zu, mit Kollegen Martin Petersdorf, der hervorragende Indie-Musik dabei hat. Ja, Starbuck, du kannst doch was sagen.
Du wolltest das Camp noch mal sagen oder? Genau, also nochmal für den Terminkalender, 8. bis 12. August. FinoFoot bei Berlin, das Chaos Communication Camp und kommendes Wochenende in Dresden, die Datenspuren.
Ja, die dürft ihr auf keinen Fall verpassen. Eine schöne, kleine, intime Veranstaltung zum Diskutieren und Lärm.
Und zum Spaß haben. Also was nochmal auch wichtig sein sollte, man kann über diese ganzen Sachen reden, sich den Mundfusselig reden, diskutieren, ohne weiteres und so weiter und so fort. Aber trotz alledem, es sind alles Menschen, die sind normale Menschen, mit denen kann man ein Fitz erzählen, Kaffee trinken, Spaß haben. Es sind nicht hier, weißt du, so Spaßbefreite Nerds.
Zum Thema Spaß haben noch irgendwie ein letzter Satz. Aus dem Irk-Channel Chaosradio gibt's die schöne Seite www.anti-terrordatei.de irgendwie klickt doch unbedingt drauf, das ist irgendwie total super gemacht, irgendwie super.
Bis demnächst, jetzt der Knife Flight.